WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE OUR
HERE TODAY FOR AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON ENVIRONMENTAL
FARMING AND INNOVATION I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
JOINED US HERE TODAY- THOSE ARE
PRESENT I'M SURE SOME WILL
TRICKLE N. AND BELIEVE WE MAY
HAVE SOME THAT ARE JOIN IS
VIRTUALLY- I LIKE TO THINK
COMMITTEE STAFF. VICTOR FRANKEL
**** NICOLE WILLIS OF ALL THE
WORK PREPARING THIS HEARING. I
ALSO WANT TO WELCOME MISS
WILLIS IS THIS IS OUR VERY
FIRST. OFFICIAL AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE HEARING I BELIEVE SHE
CAME FROM RULES COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE IT'S ADDED A HAVE A
WAITRESS- LAS AND PRODUCT FOR
THIS HE- SUB BEFORE I MAKE SOME
BRIEF UP ROOM REP REMARKS OPEN
IT UP TO MY- IT'S HERE SOME
LOGISTICAL ITEMS DUE TO THE
CONTINUING COVE IN NINETEEN
CRISIS WE CONTINUE TO PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN
THIS COMMITTEE ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING- FOR THOSE HERE IN
ATTENDANCE TODAY BOTH THE
HEARING PARTICIPANTS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PLEASE
KNOW THAT THROUGHOUT THIS
HEARING FACE COVERINGS ARE
REQUIRED. THERE TO BE WORN AT
ALL TIMES AND PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THEME IS EXPECTED TO BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. DUE TO PHYSICAL
DISTANCE YOU ACQUIREMENT. WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE LIMITED
SEATING AVAILABILITY IN THIS
ROOM. AND WE WILL BE CAREFULLY
MONITORING CAPACITY THROUGHOUT
THE HERE- IN. ADDITION TO THE
IT LIVE IN PERSON PRESENTATIONS
WE WILL RECEIVE THIS AFTER.
SOME PANELIST COULD NOT A TENSE.
WILL BE JOINED VIA THE-
CONFERENCING SO FINALLY I WOULD
ASK COLLEAGUES TO PLEASE HOLD
ANY. AND TELL END OF EACH PANEL.
AND SO WE THAT AGAIN THE- FOR
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS TO
HAVE A TO LEARN ABOUT IN FARM.
IN CALIFORNIA AND EXPLORE HOW
CAN IN OUR STATE'S CLAIM AND
THE GOALS. AS WE KNOW TWENTY
TWENTY WAS IN ON PRESS YEAR-
AND WE CONTINUE TO LIVE IN AND
WORK IN VERY CHALLENGING TIMES.
AS A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I NOW
REPRESENT AGRICULTURE IS AN
IMMENSE SOURCE OF PRIDE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY FOR MY FAMILY AND FOR
MYSELF. OUR DISTRICT THE THIRTY
DECEMBER DISTRICT INCLUDES SOME
OF THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD- IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE IN AGRICULTURAL MARVEL. YOU
KNOW WE ARE A MODEL FOR OTHER
STATES WE ARE A MODEL FOR THE
NATION'S AND THERE'S NO DOUBT
THAT THROUGHOUT HISTORY
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE HAS
PROVEN IT IS BOTH INNOVATIVE
AND RESILIENT. AND FOLLOWING MY
APPOINTMENT AS CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE WITH THE
CONSIDERATION TOWARDS THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY OUR FARMERS
AND FARM WORKERS WHEN WE GIVEN
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC I
WAS PROUD TO EMBARK ON A TWO
MONTH STATEWIDE AGRICULTURAL
TOUR. JOINED BY A LOT OF
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE- TO
MEET WITH STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND GATHER
PERSPECTIVES ON THE NEEDS OF
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. IN
NOVEMBER BASED ON STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT ON OUR TOUR. WE HELD
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
IMPACT OF WILDFIRES ON
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE- AND
TODAY ALSO BASED ON SITE VISITS
AND ENGAGEMENT WELL ON OUR AG
TOUR WE ARE HOLDING AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON A
VINYL FARMING IN CALIFORNIA. SO
I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND THE SUCCESS OF
BOTH OUR FARMERS AND- FARM
WORKERS AND I BELIEVE STRONGLY
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO BE A
WORLDWIDE LEADER IN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION. WHILE
ALSO LEADING THE WAY
ENVIRONMENTAL AND INNOVATION IN
OUR FIELDS. CALIFORNIA HAS LONG
BEEN KNOWN AND RECOGNIZED AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADER. OUR STATE
HAS SOME OF THE MOST AGGRESSIVE
CLIMATE POLICIES. AND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
IN THE COUNTRY. AND IF WE HAVE
ANY CHANCE OF MEETING OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS AND
MITIGATING THE WORST IMPACTS OF
OUR CHANGING CLIMATE.
AGRICULTURE MUST. PLAY A ROLE.
IT'S OFTEN OVERLOOKED BUT
AGRICULTURE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE OFFER
SOME OF THE MOST PROMISING
OPPORTUNITIES IN OUR FIGHT
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
ACCORDING TO ENVIRONMENTALIST
PAUL HAWKEN AGRICULTURE. HOW WE
GROW OUR FOOD HOW WE MANAGE OUR
NATURAL WORKING LANDS. MAY
REPRESENT BY FAR THE SINGLE
GREATEST SOLUTION. TO OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS AS A STATE A LOT
OF EMPHASIS HAS BEEN PLACED ON
REDUCING CARBON EMISSIONS BUT A
REDUCTION IN EMISSIONS JUST
SIMPLY ISN'T ENOUGH. YES WE
MUST REMAIN STEADFAST IN OUR
COMMITMENT TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
OF CARBON. IT IS LEADING
RESEARCHERS FROM THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD AGREE. WE MUST PRIORITIZE
AND INVEST IN CARBON CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGIES AND THERE'S NO
BETTER MORE EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO THIS THAT
SUPPORTING AND INVESTING IN
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AND
ENCOURAGING INNOVATION. IF WE
CAN PRACTICE AGRICULTURE IN A
WAY THAT FIGHTS CLIMATE CHANGE
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY CREATING A
MORE RESILIENT FOOD SYSTEM IN
OUR STATE WE MUST MAXIMIZE ALL
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE. THERE IS GREAT
POTENTIAL TO INNOVATE IN THIS
AREA AND AS CHAIR OF THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE I PLAN TO
FOSTER A VIGOROUS DEBATE
CALIFORNIA. MUST LEAD THE WAY.
AND TODAY WE WILL HEAR FROM
FARMERS RANCHERS RESEARCHERS
AND ADVOCATES ALL OF WHOM HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF ENVIRONMENT FARMING.
WE'LL HEAR ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE AND THEIR IMPACTS
THEIR CHALLENGES- AND ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE ON
CURRENT PROGRAMS AND WHAT MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO EXPAND
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
PRACTICES. I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR DISCUSSION THIS AFTERNOON
WELCOME OTHER MEMBERS TO SHARE
OPENING REMARKS VICE CHAIR
MATHIS. THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
RIVAS- I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TWO MONTH ACT OR
UP AND DOWN THE STATE. VERY
SIMILAR- THING WHEN I. GOT ONTO
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE AND-
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
TOOK THAT IN DEPTH- TIME TO GO
AND DO THAT- IS HE SAID. OUR
AGRICULTURAL EFFORTS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OR THE
CUTTING EDGE OF AG TECHNOLOGY
WE HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
INNOVATIVE PROCESS IS DONE. OUR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS RECYCLE
WATER MORE THAN A GREAT MANY
PEOPLE REALIZE. THEY RE USE%
EVERY POSSIBLE THING THAT THEY
CAN. AND THEY ARE A GREAT
EXAMPLE OF HOW TO DO THINGS
BETTER AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR ROBUST HEARING TODAY TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN CONTINUE. TO
READ NOT JUST THE COUNTRY BUT
ALSO THE WORLD IN OUR AG
TECHNOLOGIES AND LOOK AT HOW
OUR AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES ARE
EXTREMELY ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND.
AND WHAT WE CAN DO AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO HELP. KEEP
OUR FARMS AND RANCHES
CONTINUING TO GO HERE WITHIN
THE STATE AND THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN BETTER DO. TO GET SOME
OF THE RED TAPE OUT OF THEIR
WAY SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE FOOD AND FIBER FOR ALL
OF US THANK YOU. THE REST YOUR
MATHIS ANY OTHER COMMENTS I WAS
THE COMMITTEE. NOT WE WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR FIRST PANEL THIS IS
AN OVERVIEW OF CDFA IS
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING AND
INNOVATION PROGRAM. THIS FIRST
PANEL- WE ARE HONORED TODAY TO
HAVE KAREN ROSS SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE. AS YOU'LL BE
JOINING US VIRTUALLY- SECRETARY
ROSS'S SERVICES TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN AND MY OPINION IS THE
FINEST STATE SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURE THE ENTIRE COUNTRY-
PRIOR TO OUR SERVICE IN OUR
STATE SECRETARY ROSS SERVED AS
CHIEF OF STAFF TO U. S.
AGRICULTURE SECRETARY TOM
VILSACK. WHO WAS A FORMER
SECRETARY AND SOON TO BE
CURRENT SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURE. SHE HAS SPENT HER
CAREER FIGHT FINDING INNOVATIVE
WAYS FOR CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
TO CONTINUE SERVING AS A MODEL
FOR THE NATION AND WORLD SO
SECRETARY ROSS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SEVEN
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION. TO YOU AND TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- YOU
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
MAKES ME SO PASSIONATE ABOUT MY
JOB AND THAT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH OUR
FARMERS AND RANCHERS NOT ONLY
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY
BUT TO SEE WHAT IS AROUND THE
BAND AND TO CONTINUE TO
INNOVATE AND WEIGHS AROUND.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MEET THE FOOD
SECURITY NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS AS WELL AS
CONSUMERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND AROUND THE GLOBE. AND TO DO
IT IN A VERY ENVIRONMENTALLY
SOUND WAY I'M WITH THE
COMMITMENT TO SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY I WANT TO TAKE
JUST ONE MINUTE AND THE TIME
HAS BEEN ALLOTTED TO EACH JUST
PROVIDE TO A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ABOUT HOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- BEGAN TO PLAY. A
ROLE IN THIS SPACE. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE I WAS STILL A
MEMBER OF THE STATE FORTITUDE
IN AGRICULTURE AND WE WERE
CHALLENGED- BY OUR CHAIRMAN AT
THAT TIME. TO DO A STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR AGRICULTURE AND SO WE
ENDED UP GOING THROUGH. A
STATEWIDE LISTENING SESSION TO
HEAR ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AND-
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHAT DO WE
NEED TO BE DOING IN THIS TIME
OF REALLY RAPID CHANGE- TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT PATHWAY FOR THE LONG
TERM VIABILITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. THAT LED TO
ACTIVATION- AND THAT WAS THE
FRAMEWORK THAT REALLY HELPED US
PRIORITIZE OUR WORK AND THE
CLAIM IS BASED AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF. AGRICULTURE IT
WAS ONE THAT I MONTHS THAT.
THAT LEAD OUT WAS THAT WE DO
ALL THE WAS PASSED. TO ASSURE
AFTER. ADDED I'M CHANGE I WAS
JUST THE- BECAUSE AT THAT TIME
THE REPORT WAS RELEASED IN
TWENTY TWO. I DID. PROBABLY
SPEAKING WE'RE FAR ON
ADAPTATION. BUT NOW WE
UNDERSTAND THE. HUGE POWER.
AGRICULTURE TO DRIVE DOWN.
SEQUESTERED IN OUR SOIL. AND
MEDICARE. CLIMATE CHANGE THAT'S
THE A REMARK- DEVELOPED IN THE
GLOBAL. AND ONE HAS TO.
MOMENTUM BEHIND AT. IN TWENTY
TWELVE WE OR- THE KIND CHANGE
SOURCE. THIS WAS FUNDED BY A
SPECIAL CROP BLOCK. THAT WE USE
TO CONVEY A CROSSWORD. FROM
ACROSS THE STATE. TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW MAY TALKING
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE HOW ARE
THEY THINKING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND HOW DID ADAPTATION
FACTOR INTO THEIR DAILY
DECISION MAKING. IT WAS A VERY
INFORMATIVE PROCESS IT WAS
GROUNDED IN A SHARED SCIENTIFIC
UNDERSTANDING OF NOT ONLY HOW
OUR SPECIALTY CROPS IN
PARTICULAR. ARE IMPACTED BY
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT ALSO WHERE
THE OPPORTUNITIES WERE FOR US
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. AND
IT OUTLINED IN A VERY CLEAR WAY
AND IT'S STILL VERY RELEVANT
TAPER RESEARCH COMMUNITY. WHAT
WERE SOME OF THE TOOLS WHAT WAS
ON THE TECHNOLOGY PEOPLE ARE
HOPEFUL ABOUT AND WE'RE THEIR
RESEARCH CAPS TO HELP THEM TO
CONTINUE TO BE THE POWERHOUSE
OF AGRICULTURE. THEY ARE SH. WE
HAVE STATED THAT THE COUPLE
TIMES- INCLUDING IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND JUST IN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF WE WORKED WITH
A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL CONSORTIUM. TO
REALLY FOCUS ON SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ISSUES OUT OF THAT
MAP FOR. ONE OF AND OF THE
BECAUSE I. THAT HYPER. WHICH IS
AS THIS. OR WHAT ARE TO
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE WITH THE
NEED TO AS- ROBERT DOT OF
TECHNOLOGY. AND PRODUCTS. FOR
HIM. WATER WHICH COULDN'T
INCLUDE THE USE OF WATER. SO
MOISTURE SENSORS ON FARM WATER
STORAGE AND GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE WHEREVER THAT'S
POSSIBLE- IS LIKE WE ARE BEING
TO FUTURISTIC JUST TWO SHORT
YEARS LATER TWENTY FOURTEEN WE
WERE IN THE BEGINNING OF A
DROUGHT WE HAD NO IDEA HOW DO
YOU CAN HELP PROLONG. DROUGHT
REPEAT. BUT BEYOND THAT OF TWO
FOUR. WE THAT THERE IF. CLIMATE
SMART PRO- AND IT'S THE STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY. PROGRAM FIRST
WEEK PROGRAM STOCKHOLDERS
PROGRAM IT WAS THE FIRST ONE
FOR AGRICULTURE THAT FUNDED AND
INCENTIVE- TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND TO IMPROVE
WATER USE EFFICIENCY. I AM
PROUD TO SAY THAT STILL ONE OF
OUR MOST POPULAR PROGRAMS- IT
HAS BEEN OVER SUBSCRIBED EVERY
YEAR THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
OFFER THAT PROGRAM BY AT LEAST
THREE HUNDRED PERCENT. AND I'M
ALSO PLEASED BY THE NUMBER OF
FARMERS AND RANCHERS TO PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS WHICH HELPS US
LEVERAGE LEVERAGE THESE. TO THE
MAXIMUM AMOUNT POSSIBLE. THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF THE PROGRAM
WERE FUNDED BY THE CLIMATE
CHANGE INVESTMENT FUND- WE DID
RECEIVE SPENDING TWO YEARS AGO
FOR PROP SIXTY EIGHT AND THEN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- THAT WAS
PROPOSED IN JANUARY THERE'S A
TOTAL OF FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
ON THE GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE TO CONTINUE. THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM. I WOULD
I AM PLEASED TO SAY WE'VE
INVEST EIGHTY SEVEN A HALF
MILLION. IN PRIOR. WE HAVE
FUNDED EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT WE PRIDE THROUGHOUT STATE.
THE COVER OVER HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND EIGHT.
AND THEY HAVE. OVER EIGHT.
THOUSAND METRIC TONS OF CO TWO
WEEKS. WE HAVE GAS OVER TEN
YEAR WHICH IS HOW WE STRUCK. IT
ALSO IS BEING. TO READ OUR WHAT
USED BY SO. AND A HALF BILLION
GALA. AND I WAS LOVE IT WHEN
COMES UP WITH THESE THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF A PROXY SO
THOUSAND OLYMPIANS. WALLS THERE
IS A PRODUCT- AND AS A RESULT
OF THAT AND ARE. WITH U. S.
NATURAL RESOURCE CUTS SERVICE
TO UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE
TECHNICAL STATE THEY- OR FAR
CONSERVE PRACTICES. WE
ESTABLISHED OFFICE AND BY
FARMING AND IN. RECALLING FOR
START- TO ADMINISTER I MISSED
AGRICULTURAL. THAT ARE ALL HELP
OUR OFFICE THANK ON. AND
ANALYSIS. AND HAS A STAFF. FOR
ALL OF OUR WORK ACROSS. ON FILE-
A RESULT OF THE COULD. AT THE
CAPITOL PRO. I'M TO TALK TO PUT
THAT ARE. TO REDUCE NOTHING BUT
Mí
OUR DURING HER RESEARCH DEVELOP
PROGRAM. AND THEY'LL TO OR
MANAGE PROGRAM WHICH AS WE KNOW
MATH IS A IT LOOKS POLLUTANT IS
A POWERFUL GREENHOUSE GAS. AND
WITH AS A STAY THAT'S ONE STATE
NATH NOSES VERY WELL- WITH.
EMISSIONS DEFEAT JERRY
DIGESTIVE PROGRAM DEPLOYS THE
TECHNOLOGY TO CAPTURE THE
METHANE WHICH BECOMES A
RENEWABLE SOURCE FOR ELECTRICAL
GENERATION AND TRANSPORTATION
FUELS WHICH QUALIFY UNDER THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD WHICH
CURRENTLY WE HAVE A HUNDRED IN
NINETEEN DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS.
IN PLACE ALREADY ONLINE- THE
JERRY FAMILIES LOVE THIS
PROGRAM A LOT IN A STEP OVER
SUBSCRIBED JUST LAST YEAR BY
FOUR HUNDRED PERCENT. IT'S
ALLOCATED ALMOST TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE TYPES
OF PROJECTS SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. THE TERRY FAMILIES
THEMSELVES IN THE JERRY DIGEST
OR DEVELOPERS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN MATCHING
FUNDS- I WOULD SAY IT'S. VERY
VERY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. THE
ALTERNATE THE NORMALISED
PROGRAM REALLY DEALS FOR SMALL
AND MID SIZED FAMILIES AND
THEIR HERDS. HOW TO BETTER
MANAGE DRIVING OR WE'VE GOT A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN OF THOSE
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND TOGETHER WITH THE DERRY
DIGESTIVE PROGRAM WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES
BY TWO POINT THREE MILLION
METRIC TONS PER YEAR THAT'S A
PRETTY REMARKABLE AND WHAT THE
L. A. L. LET'S REFER TO AS A
VERY EFFICIENT INVESTMENT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE DOLLARS. THAT'S
THE EQUIVALENT OF REMOVING HALF
A MILLION CARS FROM OUR ROADS
SO IT'S QUITE AN ACHIEVEMENT
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT PROGRAM WHICH
HAS TWO VERY IMPORTANT ADDED
BENEFITS ONE IS RENEWABLE
ENERGY SOURCE AND TWO IS THE
PROVEN REDUCTION ODORS. FROM
FROM JERRY SO IT'S BEEN VERY
VERY POPULAR IN THE COMMUNITY
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITE PROGRAMS IS
ARE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM WHICH
HAS BOTH AND INCENTIVES FOR
FARMERS. AS WELL. AS A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT. IS I'M
IN THE FINANCIAL FOR THAT WILL
WELL PARTNER WITH OUR GROWERS
AND WITH OUR RANCHERS TO
IMPLEMENT CONSERVATION
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES AGAIN THAT
ARE BASED ON AN R. C. ASK
SCIENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
ARE PROVEN TO WORK WELL FOR THE
FARMER AND FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
THEY APPROVE STYLE HEALTH THE
SEQUESTER CARBON AND THEY
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THE DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
DESIGNED TO SHOWCASE FOR ALL SO
THAT GROUPS OF FARMERS WHO ARE
NOT YET READY TO GO DOWN THAT
PATHWAY CAN VISIT THOSE SITES
LEARN FROM THE SITE IN A NUMBER
OF THEM ARE COLLECTING THE DATA
WHICH WILL HELP US. UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE CAN DO TO DANCE EVEN
MORE OF THESE TYPES ACTRESS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE HUNDRED
EIGHTY INCENTIVE PROJECTS AND
SIXTY SIX DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS COVERING A TOTAL OF
580-001-0040 EIGHT ACRES STATE
THIS IS ALSO PART OF OUR WHOLE
OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO
HEALTHY CELLS IN ITS JOB WHICH
IS WORKING ACROSS EVERY AGENCY
THAT MAY HAVE PROGRAMS THAT
COULD BE ADAPTED TO CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE THESE TYPES OF
PRACTICES PARKS BRANCHES AS
WELL AS ADOPTING SMALL HEALTH
PRACTICES UNSTABLE PROPERTIES.
AND LANDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SH I'M HEALTHY SO PRO- HAS BEEN
BY. ARTIST ITS FOR TOO WE DO
SPEAK GAS BY OVER A TWELVE
DOLLARS. METRIC TONS PER YEAR
HE AND ONE OF THIS. THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THIS PROGRAM
IS NOT ONLY STORE ALL HEALTH
FOR LONG TERM PRODUCTIVITY
INCREASES AND FOOD SECURITY BUT
ALSO THE WATER HOLDING CAPACITY
THAT IS THE RESULT OF
INCREASING SOIL ORGANIC MATTER
AND HOLDING BACK CARBON IN OUR
SOILS. IMPROVE NUTRIENT CYCLING
AS A WAY TO PROTECT OUR
GROUNDWATER BASINS FROM THE
LEACHING OF NITRATES HELLO THE
RESULTS- AND- OF COURSE WATER
HOLDING CAPACITY FOR STATE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S. ABOUT DIVERSITY
WE KNOW THAT A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF OUR POWER DIVERSITY IT'S
LITERALLY THAT MICROBIAL.
ACTIVITY IN OUR SOILS. BOB WHAT
OF THE IMPORTANT. IN IT TO
FACING PRACTICE ON. AS A
VOLUNTARY PRACTICES. YES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND UNDER
THIS PROGRAM WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO THIRTY
THREE DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO PROVIDE GRANT APPLICATION
EXPERTISE TO HELP FARMERS A
QUIET FOR OUR PROGRAMS INTO
THEIR PROGRESS REPORTING. IT
ALSO INCLUDES. UNITY EDUCATION
SPECIALIST I'M A SMART
AGRICULTURE TO HELP ADVANCE THE
INFORMATION AND BRING MORE AND
MORE FARMERS AND RANCHERS INTO
THE PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW CAN
HELP US WITH OUR CHALLENGE. UP
ARE OUR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON
SMALL FARMS. SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS. AND IT
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
FOR US AMONG THE PEOPLE WE
COLLABORATE WITH ON THAT IN
ADDITION TO NRC ASK OUR
RESOURCE CONSERVAION DISTRICTS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION. COUNTY
FARM BUREAU'S HELP THEIR
MEMBERS I'D FOR THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS- AND OTHER PEOPLE IN
ACADEMIA AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND CDFA IS PART
OF THE FARM DEMONSTRATION
NETWORK THAT IS ALL ABOUT IT
DANCING THESE KINDS OF
PRACTICES WITH ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS. INTERPOSING I WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE'RE NOT THE ONLY
AGENCY THAT HAS PROGRAMS TO
ASSIST AGRICULTURE IN BEATING
OUR GOALS FOR CLIMATE CHANGE IN
THE STATE OUR PARTNER PROGRAMS
IN APPROPRIATIONS TO DATE. ARE
THE AGRICULTURAL REPLACEMENT
MEASURES FOR ADMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS THE FARMER PROGRAM
WHICH IS HOUSED AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
I'M WHICH HAS INVESTED STUCK
FOR THREE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
WHERE WE GET MEDIAN BENEFIT OF
REDUCING CRITERIA POLLUTANTS BY
CLEANER EQUIPMENT AND CLEANER
BURNING ENGINES BUT ALSO LONGER
TERM REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS THAT PROGRAM.
THIS IS A NOVEL ACT LANDS
CONSERVATION PROGRAM IS
ADMINISTERED BY THE STRATEGIC
COUNCIL TO DATE THAT'S A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PRESERVING
FARM AND RANCH LAND WHICH IS
ONE OF THE MOST. EFFICIENT WAYS
OF AVOIDING THE EMISSION OF
GREENHOUSE GASES WHEN WE DO
DEVELOPMENT WE KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MUCH HIGHER THIS IS A FREE
HOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AS OPPOSED
TO KEEPING THAT LAND OUR
CULTURE. OF THAT CALIFORNIA CAN-
HASN'T A HUNDRED SEVENTY POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
PRODUCTION GRAMS SB AS FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION IN ENERGY
AGRICULTURE. TODAY TO OUR
CLIMATE AND DOES PLAN OVER
BILLION DOLLARS BEEN INVESTED
IN HELPING AGRICULTURE HELP
THIS STATE. ARE CARBON. ALL I'M
HAPPY TO GET INTO HOW WE DO
THAT THE CASE METHODOLOGY AND
THE COMMON FARM TOOL THAT I
THINK I'VE USED UP ALL MY TIME
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
INTEREST I'M THRILLED THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THE CONVERSATION TODAY.
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION
SECRETARY ROSS AND YOUR
PARTICIPATION OPEN UP TO
QUESTIONS. I SHERMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SECRETARY ROSS
ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE YOU- JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
A COUPLE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING OVER THE
YEARS- WHEN IT COMES TO THE
DAIRY METHANE CAPTURED IN THE
CARB CREDITS. I KNOW THERE ARE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT-
RENEWABLE GAS BEING SENT INTO
THE GAS PIPELINES IN A LOSS OF
IT THAT GOING TO VEHICLE FUELS-
KNOWING THAT IF THAT GOES INTO-
PIPELINES THEN THAT'S GOING TO
INCREASE THE COST OF
MANUFACTURERS- IN THOSE THINGS
AND WE'RE GOING TO LOSE THOSE
CARBON CREDITS- MAKING THE
PROGRAM WORK. SO WHAT WHAT IS
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AIRPORT RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
KEEPING THOSE CREDITS TO GO
TOWARDS. VEHICLE FUELS AND THEN
MAINTAINING. THIS RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS- MODEL TO GO
TOWARDS SAY LOCAL FLEETS WITH
TRANSPORTATION. THERE'S A LOT
OF MOVEMENT AROUND THAT SPACE-
THAT'S MY FIRST QUESTION FOR
YOU AND I HAVE ONE MORE. THE
EASY ONE FIRST AND THIS IS PART
OF A MUCH LARGER CONVERSATION
ACROSS THE DISTRICT. COSTED
MINISTRATION- AND ESPECIALLY
NOW THAT WE HAVE A NEW CHAIR AT
THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD I'M
SURE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT ALL OF THESE PROJECTS
THAT GOT THROUGH TO YOU SEE
THAT PIPELINE INJECTION SO THAT
THE SAFETY. CAN BE ASSURED- I
KNOW THAT THE DAIRY SECTOR IS
VERY INTERESTED IN BEING A PART
OF HOW POWER AND ALL THOSE
DIESEL TRUCKS THAT GO UP AND
DOWN NINETY NINE IT I FIVE
MINUTES TAKE THE BASENESS. THIS
IS PART OF A LARGER DISCUSSION
THAT WE ARE HAVING AROUND THE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES AND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND SO I DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR DAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS BUT IT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ONE FOR THE
LONG TERM ECONOMICS OF HOW
THESE THINGS WORK IF THERE
NEEDS TO BE IT. HOW DO WE AVOID
DISRUPTION WITH THE PROGRAM
THAT'S THAT'S WORKING
SUCCESSFULLY FOR THE TERRY
FARMERS FOR THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
IMPROVE MANAGEMENT PRACTICES ON
JERRY FARMS SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
WHICH ARE TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
YOU AN ANSWER TO THAT ON
TUESDAY ESPECIALLY OUT OF
RESPECT FOR MY COLLEAGUES IN
THE CHAIR AT THE AIRPORT THANK
YOU. ARE ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND-
SPECIALLY WITH WITH THE NEW
CHAIR ON THE AIRPORT- I'VE HAD
SEVERAL STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS-
LOCALLY RACHAEL IN THE
DISTRICTS SINCE WE ARE THE
LARGEST. DAIRY AND GO OVER ONE
OF THE LARGEST TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDORS AS WELL. YES I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF EFFORTS TO
LOOK AT LOCAL FLEETS GOING
TOWARDS- NATURAL GAS IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING- SO
IF YOU COULD LOOK ME IN WAIT
WITH THAT NIGHT MORE THAN HAPPY
TO BRING STAKEHOLDERS IN AS
WELL. AS LOOK FOR A- LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION-
ANOTHER ONE. RELATED WITH-
YOU'D MENTION THE- FORMER
PROGRAM AND THIS IS WE HAVE
DISCUSSED- BACK WHEN WE'RE- CAP
AND TRADE TO FIX SOME OF THE
KINKS. AS FAR AS UPGRADING
ENGINE TYPES. BECAUSE AT THE
TIME YOU WE WERE NOT ALLOWED
TO- SWITCH ENGINE TYPE SO WE
WERE GIVEN THE PROGRAM WHERE
YOU COULD GO FROM THE OLD
DIESEL TO A NEW DIESEL OR
NATURAL GAS AND NATURAL GAS-
BUT NOT SWITCH SAY FROM DIESEL
TO SOLAR. AND I JUST WANNA TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON THAT AND SEE IF
THOSE CHANGES- HAVE COME INTO
PLAY OVER THE YEARS LIKE WE HAD
PLANNED ON THEM. AND HOW ALL
THAT IS GOING. IT IS PROBABLY
OF ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT ONE
IS THE MOST POPULAR ONE AND
PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE VERY. EDS
POSITIVE IMPACT AIR QUALITY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. AND SO. IT IS. FROM
EVERYTHING THAT I HEAR FROM MY
STAKEHOLDERS IS THAT. GRAHAM
WAS WORKING REALLY REALLY WELL-
AND THE INTEREST ESPECIALLY NOW
WITH OUR EXECUTIVE ORDER US
YOU. SHOULD BE A CALLS. AND
GOING TO WHEREVER IT IS
POSSIBLE AND TECHNICALLY
FEASIBLE- ALLEGED VEHICLES I
THINK YOU'LL CONTINUE TO SEE
ALL PROPRIETY. OF OPTIONS IN
THAT PROGRAM. I'M THE ONE THING
WE DON'T WANT TO O IS ALLOW
FOR INTERRUPTION OF THE SONS.
BECAUSE IT IS ACCOMPLISHING
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY.
REDUCTION WE- AND ONE OF OUR-
SEVERELY. BASINS IN TOUCH. I SO
WE'RE VERY PLEASED AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDED. ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND HIS PROPOSED BUDGET FOR
THAT PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE NOW THIS IS AN
INVESTMENT THAT'S WORTH MAKING
IT HAS HUGE PUBLIC BENEFIT.
YEAH AND HELPING TO REDUCE THE
COST TO OUR FARMERS AND
INCLUDING A PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS. ISSUES SUCH. NO I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE I KNOW IT IT
HELPS- REMOVE A LOT OF THE KNOX
WHICH IS THE HARSHER OF AIR
POLLUTANTS ON ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREA SO IF THERE'S ANYTHING
ALONG THOSE LINES YOU AS ALWAYS
YOU KNOW I'M HERE TO HELP ALL
ALONG THOSE LINES. LIKEWISE
ANYWAY. THAT'S THE END OF MY
QUESTIONS GOOD TO SEE YOU
SECRETARY THANK YOU THANKS SO
MUCH. RUSSIA HAS OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I THINK I HAVE A
REALLY EASY QUESTION SECRETARY
ROSS- POST TO MY- COLLEAGUE ON
MY RIGHT- YOU KNOW I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUMMARY YOU
PROVIDED ABOUT ALL THE PROGRAMS
OFFERED THROUGH- YOU KNOW THE
OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENT FARMING
IN INNOVATION. E. D. DID YOU
KNOW HOW MANY OTHER STATES HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SIMILAR. SO
OKLAHOMA AT ONE POINT- INVESTED
AND HEALTHY SOURCE PRACTICES
AND THE STATE OF IOWA HAS
INVESTED AND COVER CROPPING TO
ADDRESS THEIR NITRATE RUNOFF
PROBLEM. BUT NO OTHER STATE HAS
A SUITE OF CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES- WITH
THE KIND OF INVESTMENT THE
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE. OR WITH
THE QUANTIFICATION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTIONS AND THAT'S WHY I WAS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO WORK
WITH U. S. GAAP MAKE THEIR
COMBAT ARMOR. AT METHODOLOGY
TOOL WORK FOR SPECIALTY CROPS-
AND SO WE I CAN SAY I AM VERY
PROBABLY FOR THE ONLY STATE
THAT HOUSE THIS WHOLE SUITE OF
PRACTICES THAT WE COST SHARE
WITH OUR FARMERS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
THAT WE MAJORETTES AND QUANTIFY
IT AND. ASSIGN YEARS. I
PRACTICE TO GO WITH. SO IT'S A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
CALIFORNIA'S MADE AS A VERY
IMPORTANT SIGNAL TO THE MARKET
PLACE AND OTHERS WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN FINDING SOLVE
HEALTH PRACTICES WE ENCOURAGE
THEM TO LOOK AT OUR SUITE OF
PRACTICES THAT ARE BASED ON
SCIENCE BETTER KNOWN TO FARMERS
AND RANCHERS AND WE'D LOVE TO
LEVERAGE PRIVATE SECTOR DOLLARS
PROGRESS WELL. WELL THANK YOU I
OPPOSITE THAT WE HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION FROM SOME A MEMBER
LEVINE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CARE THINKS HER FOR CALLING
THIS MEETING SECRETARY ROSS
GREAT TO- TO SEE VIRTUALLY.
THANK YOU FOR. YEAH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDER. CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP OF- DEPARTMENT. AND
AND YOU'VE BEEN A GREAT
PARTNER- GREAT PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN A GREAT PARTNER
TO ME. AND OF COURSE TO IT TO
AGRICULTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I REALLY ENJOYED
HEARING OR APPRECIATED HEARING-
YOUR PLUG FOR HEALTHY SOILS AND
GLAD THAT YOU LIKE IT I THINK
IT'S FANTASTIC FOR OUR STATE
FOR. DROUGHT TOLERANCE FOR
CARBON SEQUESTRATION FOR SO
MANY REASONS. AND AND I KNOW
THAT A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WE
MISSED A LITTLE BIT OF FUNDING-
THEN WE COULD GO BACK UP AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE SEEN.
OUR FURTHER INVESTMENT IN THAT
PROGRAM INTO THE FUTURE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FISHING AT. AND WE HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD. GOOD TO SEE SECRETARY
ROSS FIRST TIME ON THIS
COMMITTEE AND SO I'M SITTING
HERE NOODLING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT A POTENTIAL QUESTIONS SO-
HE- I THINK ABOUT MY DISTRICT-
IN PARTICULAR WITH RELATION TO
FIRES AND ALL THE GREENHOUSE
GASES THAT WE- IN YOUR WE TALK
A LOT ABOUT HEALTHY SOILS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. ARE THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL FOR FARMERS RANCHERS
AND GRAZING- GRANTS BECAUSE WE
CAN IF WE CAN GRACE SOME OF
THESE AREAS THAT ARE OVER-GROUND POSSIBLY. WE CAN REDUCE
THE IMPACTS OF FIRE AND PROTECT
THE ENVIRONMENT AND I USE AN
EXAMPLE OF THE POPLIN FIELD
STATION WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT
SO. VERY STARK CONTRAST A
COUPLE FIRES A COUPLE YEARS
AGO. WHERE YOU HAD AN AREA THAT
WAS GRAZED NEXT TO AN AREA THAT
WASN'T CRAZY IN A FIRE WENT
THROUGH IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN MONTHS AND THAT THE
TIME THE LARGEST FIRE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE STATE. IT WAS IT
WAS A IT WAS THERE A YEAR LATER
THE STARK. DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE TWO PIECES OF PROPERTY. ONE
WAS ONE ONE WAS ALREADY
RECOVERING AND THE OTHER PART
MAY NEVER RECOVER SO AS WE ARE
LOOKING AT INITIATIVES THAT
WILL HELP REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES- SOME OF THAT. I HOPE CAN
BE LANDSCAPE RELATED FOR FIRE
PREVENTION BECAUSE- THE STORY I
READ SAID THAT HALF OF THE
POLLUTION. THAT WAS LIBERATED
LAST YEAR CAME FROM FOREST
FIRES SO JUST IT'S JUST MORE OF
A COMMENTARY I THINK YOU'RE
WELL AWARE OF THIS- BUT- BUT-
YEAH. NOT SURE I'M NOT EVEN
SURE WHERE THIS FALLS IN QUITE
FRANKLY. BUT IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT POINT IS SOMETHING
THAT I JUST SPOKE AT OUTLOOK
pWILDFIRES AND- IMPACTS TO
AGRICULTURE. AND SO I THINK
THIS WE ALREADY FUND PRESCRIBED
ROTATIONAL GRAZING PRACTICES AS
PART OF HEALTHY STYLE WE FUND
APPLICATION OF COMPOST AND
RANGE THAT FOR HEALTHY SOIL.
AND IT'S REALLY WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH MY
COLLEAGUES OF RESOURCES AGENCY
AS WE DO ALL THE- WE CAN. FOR
WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
UNDERSTANDING THE ROLE OF
AGRICULTURE AND BAD CLEARLY.
ROTATIONAL GRAZING AND ALLOWING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IS ONE
CRITICAL PIECE OF THAT PICTURE
AS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE UP A
CONVERSATION WITH MY COLLEAGUE
SECRETARY PROFESS. AND SEE IF
THERE COULD BE SOME. WORDS WHAT
OF OUR PROGRAM I DON'T KNOW ONE
IT WOULD BE BETTER I'M TO DOING
THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT YOU
CAN HAVE. IT AND- ALL. THANK
YOU AND I JUST WANNA. BIG FAN
OF THE SWEET PROGRAM AND
THROUGH THE WORK IS DONE THERE
I WISH WE COULD FIND MORE
RESOURCES FOR THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S SOME REALLY INNOVATIVE
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING OUT
THERE WHEN YOU'VE GOT A PROGRAM
THAT'S 3100% OVERSUBSCRIBED.
THAT I TO TELL SOMEBODY
SOMETHING AND WE REALLY NEED TO
FIND RESOURCES TO HELP BECAUSE
THERE ARE SOME PRACTICES THAT I
KNOW OR SEQUESTERING HUGE
AMOUNTS OF CARBON IN THE SOIL
AND ONE IN PARTICULAR MY
DISTRICT. I WOULD PUT A PLUG IN
THEM ONTO A PUBLICLY IS A
LITTLE IS A LITTLE ORGANIC FARM
CALLED FORTUNATE FARM THE YOU
SPENT GRAIN FROM A BREWERY. THE
ONLY ONE OF THREE- NON GMO OR
BREWERIES IN. INSTEAD OF. I GET
I GET THAT RIGHT ANYWAY. YEAH
IN IN IN THE COUNTRY AND THEY
HAVE SOME QUIZZICAL THE USE
THAT SPENT SO AS A WAY TO AMEND
THEIR SOIL AND THEY
SOUTHWESTERN MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
CARBON IN IN THEIR SOIL AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S OTHER OTHER
THINGS OUT THERE THAT COULD BE
DOING THAT AND I GUESS MY POINT
ON THIS IS. THESE ARE OUR-
RELATIVELY LOW COST LOW IMPACT.
AND I YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE WE
CHASE TECHNOLOGY ALL THE TIMES
BUT I THINK SOMETIMES WE REALLY
DO MISS. REALLY SUBSTANTIVE
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN WE CHASE
TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT I LIKE TO
SAY SOMETIMES IS THE SHINY
SHINY OBJECT IN THE IN THE
DISTANCE OF THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR SUCH A CONTEST. WHAT
SECRETARY ROSS AGAIN WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE TIME
FOR US AND- YOU KNOW FOR- FOR-
ALL OF THE ANSWERS AND- YOUR
FEEDBACK SO LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND- I'M SURE WE'LL
SEE YOU OON. I HOPE SO THANKS
VICTOR. OKAY SO MOVING TO OUR
SECOND PANEL IN OUR SECOND
PANEL FEATURES A DIVERSE SET OF
THREE FARMERS FROM THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. ALL OF WHOM HAVE
HAVE LIVED AND BREATHED-
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING IN THEIR
OPERATIONS THEY HAVE FIRST HAND
REAL LIFE EXPERIENCE FOR WHAT'S
WORKING. I AND ALSO WHAT MORE
IS NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT
ENVIRONMENT FARMING IS
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS STATE. FIRST
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME GRAMMY
AWARD WINNING SINGER SONG
WRITER OCEANSIDE AVOCADO GROWER
J. SIN RAZ- SO JASON IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY BY VIDEO
CONFERENCE MR MORASS GRACIOUSLY
HOSTED ME ON. A TOUR OF HIS
AVOCADO AND COFFEE RANCH IN
NOVEMBER AS WE WERE ON OUR AG
TOUR- HIS PASSION FOR ORGANIC
AND SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
WAS. VERY VERY CLEAR YOU KNOW
AND SO JASON WELCOME- YOU KNOW
THIS MAY BE THE FIRST. AND
HOPEFULLY NOT THE LAST TIME
THAT WE HAVE A GRAMMY AWARD
WINNING SINGER SONG WRITER
PRESENT IN THE COMMITTEE OF
AGRICULTURE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
RIVAS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
AM JASON RANSOM APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY PASSION
FOR REGENERATIVE FARMING WITH
YOU TODAY. I FARM AVOCADOS
ALONGSIDE GROWING COFFEE
BANANAS IN PASSION FRUIT. IN
ADDITION TO BEING A FARMER I
ALSO DO A LITTLE MUSIC. I'LL
SHARE MORE ABOUT MY FARM IN MY
STORY SHORTLY BUT I FIRST WANT
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH AN OVERVIEW
OF CALIFORNIA'S GREAT AVOCADO
INDUSTRY. AS TO THAT HEY I AM
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AVOCADO COMMISSION.
CALIFORNIA FARMERS GROW OVER
90% OF THE TOTAL DOMESTIC
AVOCADO PRODUCTION WITH FLORIDA
WHY MAKING UP THE REMAINING TEN
PERCENT. CALIFORNIA PRODUCES
1100% OF THE U. S. TRANSCRIBED.
WITH THE READY REPRESENTING 95%
OF CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL
PRODUCTION. CALIFORNIA HAS
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND COMMERCIAL
AVOCADO FARMERS WHO FARM ON
ABOUT FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
ACRES. MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
AVOCADO FARMERS COME FROM MULTI
GENERATIONAL FAMILY FARMS WITH
THE AVERAGE GROUP SIZE AROUND
TWENTY TO THIRTY ACRES.
CALIFORNIA'S AVOCADO ANNUAL
PRODUCTION AVERAGES BETWEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION POUNDS AND IS GROWN
PRIMARILY IN THE COUNTIES OF
SAN DIEGO RIVERSIDE VENTURA
SANTA BARBARA AND SAN LUIS
OBISPO. CALIFORNIA AVOCADO
FARMERS HAVE AN AVERAGE
FARMGATE VALUE OF THREE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THREE MILLION PER
YEAR BASED ON THE LAST TEN
YEARS. FOR TWENTY TWENTY
CALIFORNIA AVOCADO FARMERS AND
PACKERS EMPLOYED NEARLY FIFTEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS AND
GENERATED ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT.
LABOR INCOME TOTALED SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
AND ALMOST FORTY ONE MILLION
INDIRECT BUSINESS TAXES WAS
GENERATED BY GROWERS AND
PACKERS. IN TWO THOUSAND THE
TOTAL US CONSUMPTION OF HASS
AVOCADOS WAS FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE MILLION POUNDS.
FAST FOR TWENTY YEARS THE TOTAL
U. S. I HAVE A KIND OF
CONSUMPTION IN TWENTY TWENTY
INCREASED TO TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION POUNDS AN INCREDIBLE
FOUR HUNDRED. PLUS PERCENT
INCREASE. DURING THAT TIME
CALIFORNIA'S U. S. MARKET SHARE
WENT FROM 66% TWO THOUSAND TO
JUST 13% IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
INCREASED IMPORT VOLUMES COME
PRIMARILY FROM MEXICO. 80% OF
THE TOTAL U. S. VOLUME LAST
YEAR. CALIFORNIA AVOCADO
FARMERS INPUT COSTS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN OUR
OFF SHORE FARMERS WATER COSTS
CAN RUN AS HIGH AS EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED PER ACRE FOOT. WITH AN
AVERAGE YEARLY COST OF SIXTY
THREE HUNDRED PER ACRE AND
LABOR HOURLY RATES AVERAGING
EIGHTEEN DOLLARS OR MORE PER
HOUR. FARMERS ARE CONTINUING TO
FACE RAPIDLY INCREASING LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE COSTS. AND AS WITH
ANY BUSINESS FARMERS MUST MAKE
PROFIT TO REMAIN VIABLE. IF AT
THE END OF THE DAY WERE NOT
PROFITABLE ANY EFFORTS TO
CHANGE AND IMPROVE OUR
SUSTAINABILITY PRACTICES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
FARMING THEY JUST WON'T MATTER.
UNLIKE MOST BUSINESSES FARMERS
ARE PRICE TAKERS NOT PRICE
SETTERS WE ARE AT THE MERCY OF
CURRENT MARKET PRICING WE
INVEST ALL YEAR LONG TO GROW
OUR CROPS. AND WE PRAY THAT THE
FARM GATE PRICE WILL AT A
MINIMUM COVER OUR INPUT COSTS
SO THAT WE CAN AT LEAST. BREAK
EVEN. THE CALIFORNIA AVOCADO
PRODUCTION CONTRIBUTES TO
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENT AND
COMMUNITIES. WE PROVIDE
BENEFITS SUCH AS SERVING A
HEDGE AGAINST THE SPREAD OF
WILDFIRES. WE PROVIDE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION EROSION CONTROL
OPEN SPACE PRESERVATION AND
INCREASE AND IMPROVE AIR
QUALITY. WE ARE ESSENTIALLY
IRRIGATED PERENNIAL FARMLANDS.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT AVOCADO
GROWERS HAD A NET SEQUESTRATION
OF CARBON. SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN KISS THE GROUND A NEW
DOCUMENTARY ON NETFLIX WHICH
EXPLAINS EXAMINES HOW CHILLING
HAS NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR
ECOLOGY HEALTH AND CLIMATE AND
FOCUSES ON REGENERATIVE FARMING
TO RESTORE DEGRADED LANDS AND
FACILITATE HARBINGER ARE DOWN.
ONCE AN AVOCADO GROWERS PLANTED
NO TELLING OCCURS WE DON'T
DISTURB THE SOIL MOST TREES
REMAIN IN THE GROUND FOR UP TO
FIFTY YEARS MORE. THE TREES IN
MY GROUP HAD OUTLIVED THE
PREVIOUS OWNER AND I EXPECT THE
TREES THAT I PLANTED TO OUTLIVE
ME. AND AVOCADO GROVE CREATES
NATURAL LEAF LITTER WHICH
DECOMPOSE INTO THE SOIL HELPING
TO REGENERATE INTO HEALTHY
SOILS THAT SEQUESTER CARBON
INCREASE. THE LANDSCAPE. AS WE
KNOW HEALTHY SOIL LEADSTO A
HEALTHY LIFE THERE UNDERNEATH
EVERY FOOTSTEP ARE HUNDREDS OF
MILES OF MYCELIAL FUNGI WHICH
CONNECT TO. LANCE BE ON OUR
OWN- SMALL FARM EIGHT RIDGES.
SO THE MORE WE CAN ENCOURAGE
AND INSPIRE HEALTHY LAND
MANAGEMENT FOR ALL THE
HEALTHIER OUR STATE WILL BE A
SPONGE FOR WATER AND CARBON. I
BEGAN FARMING AVOCADOS AS A
HOBBY INTEREST IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND IT BECAME A
BUSINESS FOR ME IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. WHEN I SAW I NEED TO
CREATE A DIRECT TO CONSUMER
BUSINESS TO BE ABLE TO REALLY
COMPETE IN THE MARKETPLACE. I
FOUND IT IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
MAKE A PROFIT JUST ON AVOCADOS
ALONE- BECAUSE AS I SAID WE'RE
LUCKY IF WE CAN BREAK EVEN. SO
I BEGAN TO PLANT OTHER CROPS
DIVERSE TO FIVE MY LANDSCAPE.
ARE ADDING COFFEE BETWEEN MY
ROSE- AND BANANAS EVEN HOW TO
LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL REVENUE-
AGAIN CORREGGIO TREES AND
HARDLY DISTURBING THE SOIL.
KEEPING UP WITH ALL THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL IS.
DAUNTING IT REALLY IS IT'S
TOUGH IN GETTING GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S RECENTLY RELEASED
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN HE
FOCUSES ON BUILDING RESILIENCE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND I LOVE
THAT WORD- BECAUSE IN THE FACE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. WE AS
AVOCADO GROWERS I FEEL ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THAT RESILIENCE
THAT WE NEED. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
SAID IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO THE
SCALE OF THE CLIMATE CHALLENGE
OUR STATE IS FACING CALIFORNIA
ALSO NEEDS A COMPREHENSIVE AND
WELL FUNDED CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BOND. TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
IMMEDIATE CLIMATE RISKS
INCLUDING WILDFIRE EXTREME HEAT
DROUGHT AND FLOODING. A BOND
WITH XCELERATED INVESTMENTS
IMPROVING CLIMATE RESILIENCE
STRATEGIES THAT SAFEGUARD BOTH
HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AS I HAVE SHARED
CALIFORNIA AVOCADO GROWERS ARE
ALREADY PART OF BUILDING
RESILIENCE TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND IT IS IMPORTANT WE FIND A
WAY TO BE RECOGNIZED. FOR OUR
EXISTING CONTRIBUTIONS. IN
CONCLUSION. AVOCADO TREES IN
CALIFORNIA CHECK THE
ENVIRONMENT WE ENHANCE THE
ECONOMY AND WE IMPROVE
COMMUNITIES SCIENTIFIC DATA
SHOWS THAT AVOCADO TREES
CAPTURE CARBON AND YET
CALIFORNIA'S CAP AND TRADE
RULES DO NOT FINANCIALLY
RECOGNIZE THIS BENEFIT WHICH IS
OFFERED TO MANY OTHER
INDUSTRIES. FAILING TO PROVIDE
SUCH SUPPORT WHEN COMBINED WITH
INCREASING AVOCADO IMPORTS AND
SKYROCKETING PRODUCTION COSTS
IS CREATING AN UNMANAGEABLE
FINANCIAL SQUEEZE FOR AVOCADO
FARMERS. AND IS HASTENING
URBANIZATION. ESPECIALLY RIGHT
HERE IN MY HEART. FOR THOSE AN
AVOCADO INDUSTRY THE NEED IS
OBVIOUS AND THE SOLUTION IS
SIMPLE WITH YOUR SUPPORT AND
AVOCADO FARMERS WORKING IN
COOPERATION WITH CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TOGETHER WE CAN
DEVELOP A PROTOCOL WHICH
ESTABLISHES CARBON
SEQUESTRATION CREDITS FOR BOTH
ESTABLISHED AND NEWLY PLANTED
TREES. CALIFORNIA BENEFITS FROM
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND ACRES OF
AVOCADO TREES MANY ARE PLANTED
ON SLOPES HILLSIDES WHERE
LITTLE ELSE CAN BE PRODUCED
PROVIDING MULTIPLE IMPORTANT
BENEFITS SUCH AS REDUCED BED
VEGETATION WHICH ROUTE WHICH
FUELS FOREST FIRES. ARE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEANSING OF
CARBON THOUSANDS OF JOBS A
BUFFER TO URBAN SPRAWL AND OF
COURSE THE BEST TASTING MOST
NUTRITIOUS AVOCADOS IN THE
UNITED STATES AND BEYOND WE
HAVE A TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY
BEFORE US CALIFORNIA FARMING
AND CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT. TO
BE GREAT STEWARDS OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT CAN CO EXIST THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN REVERSING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME
AND INTEREST I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS. WHAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
JASON I'M REALLY GLAD THAT YOU-
SPOKE ABOUT- THE UNIQUE
OPERATION YOU HAVE WITH THE
COFFEE IN THE BANANAS GROWING
WITHIN THE AVOCADO GROW I WOULD
DOUBT THAT WAS VERY SURPRISING
TO ME AND- I'M GLAD THAT YOU
MENTIONED. SO AND THEN YES WE
I'M SURE WE WILL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF THE
PANEL- THE SECOND- THE SPEAKER
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME CHRISTINE.
K. GAMP EARLY RIGHT GAMPER
LEAGUE. YOU CAN COME TO THE
TABLE IF YOU LIKE. THAT'S FINE-
AND SO SHE IS HERE WITH US- AND
SO MS KIMBERLY IS A SECOND
GENERATION ALMOND FARMER AND A
BEEKEEPER SHE AND HER BROTHER
ERIC FARM FORTY ACRES OF
ALMONDS NEAR TURLOCK IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY- AND ANOTHER
NINETY THREE ACRES IN NEARBY
GUSTINE SO MISS CAMPOLI THANK
YOU- FOR BEING WITH US AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR COMMENTS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY I AM VERY EXCITED TO
PRESENT TO YOU THE ALLMAN
INDUSTRIES TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
GOALS. THREE YEARS AGO THE
ALMOND BOARD MEMBERS AND SENIOR
STAFF MATT KERR ABOUT A NEW
PATH FOR THE ALMOND INDUSTRY.
ONE THAT RECOGNIZE OUR CHANGING
CLIMATE AND OUR CHANGING WORLD.
ONE THAT KEPT US TWO STEPS
AHEAD INSTEAD OF PLAYING CATCH
UP. WE WANTED TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION. THE CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT MEETING RESULTED IN FOUR
GOALS. RIGHT THERE. REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF WATER TO GROW
POUND OF ALMONDS BY 20%
INCREASE IN THE ADOPTION OF
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY PEST
MANAGEMENT BY 25% REDUCING OUR
DUST AT HARVEST BY 50% AND
BECOMING A ZERO WASTE INDUSTRY
WITH NOT ONLY THE WHOLE AND
SHALL. BECOME A VALUABLE CO
PRODUCTS BUT WITH THE WOODY
BIOMASS FROM THE TREES BEING
UTILIZED. I WILL START. YOU
HAVE THE WRONG SLIDES M. GO
AHEAD DOESN'T GO ONE MORE AHEAD.
THERE YOU GO. I WILL START WITH
ZERO WASTE HISTORICALLY THE
WOODY BIOMASS FROM THE ORCHARD
REMOVAL WAS BURNED AND THEN
CAME CO GENERATION PLANTS
OFFERING ONE OPTION TO WHICH-
TO UTILIZE THE SHREDDED
ORCHARDS. FARMERS COULD
MITIGATE THE COST OF THE
ORCHARD REMOVAL WITH THE
REVENUE IT GENERATED BUT WE
KNOW CO GENERATION IS BEING
PHASED OUT. NOW AFTER YEARS OF
ALMOND BOARD FUNDED RESEARCH WE
ARE RECYCLING WHOLE ORCHARDS
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT NOT
ONLY IS CARBON SEQUESTERED BUT
THE WATER HOLDING CAPACITY OF
THE SOIL IS INCREASED BY UP
220% FOR GROWER LIKE ME THAT IS
NOT JUST A SELLING POINT.
THAT'S A NO BRAINER. A GAME
CHANGER SPECIALLY AND WATER
CHALLENGED AREAS. TWO YEARS AGO
WE CHIPPED IN INCORPORATED THE
FIRST TO TWENTY ACRES AND WE'LL
DO ANOTHER NINETY TWO ACRES
THIS FALL AT THE ONSET OF OUR
FIRST PROJECT GRANTS DID NOT
EXIST. BUT DID BECOME AVAILABLE
THROUGH HEALTHY SOILS IN THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD A WEEK
AFTER WE SPREAD OUR LAST CHIP
SO YOU BETTER BELIEVE I HAVE MY
APPLICATION AND FOR THE NEXT
NINETY TWO ACRES. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
TRANSFORMATIVE UNDERTAKING IS
COSTLY. WITH EXPENSIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT GROWERS WOULD OR
COULD NEVER OUT. DOING THE
RIGHT THING IS NEVER CHEAP. THE
FINANCIAL BENEFITS ARE NOT
IMMEDIATE AND ARE SPECIALLY
HARD FOR SMALL GROWERS WHO DO
NOT BENEFIT FROM THE ECONOMIES
OF SCALE. THE ALMOND INDUSTRY
HAS ALREADY BEEN REDUCING ITS
WATER USE PER POUND OF NUTS
OVER THE LAST. TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AS A MAJORITY OF FARMERS
TO SWITCH FROM FLOOD TO MY
CHRIS WRANGLER DRIP OR
SUBSURFACE IRRIGATION. NOW
THERE ARE FARMERS WHO HAVE
NEVER EVEN FLOODED THEIR
ORCHARDS PRECISION IRRIGATION
USING TREE BIOLOGY COMPUTER
TECHNOLOGY AND ADVANCED
EQUIPMENT. COMBINED WITH
INCREASED WATER HOLDING
CAPACITY CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR WATER SAVINGS WERE WE
DIDN'T THINK WE COULD SQUEEZE
OUT ANYMORE. OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS OUR FIRM HAS USE
NRCS GRANTS TO CHANGE FROM
FLOOD TO MIKE REYES WRANGLERS
BUT NOW WE ARE TURNING TO SWEEP
PROGRAM TO HELP US IMPROVE
FURTHER. HAVING A COST SHARE
HAS ALLOWED US TO PUT IN AN
EFFICIENT. I'M SORRY THIS TURN
IN THE WRONGFUL. YOU GUYS OF
THE RUGS LAID FLAT WELL TO STOP
THEIR. HAVE YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE
THE LOUDEST TO PUT IN AN
EFFICIENT YOU'RE ENGAGED IN
SYSTEM WE MIGHT OPPOSE BOEHNER
FOR GOD. IT MAKES THE
FERMENTABLE DOABLE WITHOUT
GRANTS WE WOULD NOT HAVE PUT
INTO SOIL MOISTURE MONITORING
STATIONS FROM WHICH WHICH
INFORM OUR DECISIONS. ON OUR
WEBSITE ORCHARD WE HAVE TAKEN
WATER SAVING TO A WHOLE NEW
LEVEL OUT OF NECESSITY FROM
HAVING SEEN ZERO WATER
ALLOTMENTS ALL TOO FREQUENTLY.
OUR INDUSTRY HAS LEARNED MUCH
FROM THE DROUGHT AND THAT
THREAT ALWAYS LOOMS LARGE
SPECIFICALLY ON OUR SITE WE
HAVE LEARNED THREE STUDIES
FUNDED BY THE ALMOND BOARD AND
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
RESEARCHERS TO USE SOIL
MOISTURE MONITORING TO DELAY
THE ONSET OF IRRIGATION. TO USE
DEFICIT YOU'RE A NATION
STRATEGIES AND EVAPORATE
TRANSPIRATION RATES TO
STRATEGICALLY SCHEDULE
IRRIGATION. THE RECENTLY
pBLOCK UTILIZED HERE BUT NOT
HERE. KIND OF- HAS A FOUR FOOT
RADIUS WHICH WILL LATER EXPAND
TO EIGHT FEET AND THIS ALLOWS
US TO REDUCE OUR WATER USED BY
ALMOST 50% AND DISCOURAGE WEED
GROWTH SIMPLY PUT NO WATER NO
WEEKS. DON'T CHANGE THIS LIFE
HERE TWO MONTHS LATER IN THE
SAME ORCHARD YOU CAN SEE OR NOT
HOW EVENLY THE TREES HAVE GROWN
WITH TARGETED FERTILIZER
APPLICATION AND NO COMPETITION
FROM WEEDS WE'LL SEE THOSE
PICTURES IN A BET. THE CENTERS
OF THE ROSE REPRESENTING TWO
THIRDS OF THE ACREAGE TO THIS
DAY HAVE NEVER BEEN SPRAYED
WITH HERBICIDE. AND THAT GETS
ME TO OUR THIRD GOAL YOU CAN
STAY HERE. ADOPTION IN THE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY PEST
MANAGEMENT NO THE SYNERGIES
BETWEEN OUR ZERO WASTE WATER
AND PEST MANAGEMENT GOALS OVER
THE YEARS GROWERS PESTICIDE USE
HAS TRENDED DOWN. AND OUR
TECHNOLOGY AND MONITORING HAS
ALLOWED FOR PRECISION
APPLICATION AND TARGETING OF
PESTS ALMOND BOARD FUNDED
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT DORMANT
SPRAYS COULD BE ELIMINATED PAST
MONITORING HELPED US TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY TIME OR ELIMINATE
SOME OF OUR CROP PROTECTION
MATERIALS. AND HERE WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE MORE RECENTLY WE
HAVE BEEN EXPLORING COVER CROPS
IN OUR ORCHARDS AND LOOKING AT
THEIR BENEFITS TO NOT JUST
HONEY BEES AND NATIVE
POLLINATORS BUT TO BENEFICIAL
INSECTS TO CONTROL PESTS I
CANNOT SAY ENOUGH ABOUT THE
BENEFITS. OF COVER CROPS AND
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM WHICH
PROMOTES AND FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTS THEIR USE. GRANTS HELP
TO INCREASE THIS PRACTICES
REACH ESPECIALLY WITH SMALLER
GROWERS. ON OUR FARM I HAVE
PERSONALLY OBSERVED HERBICIDE
RESISTANT WEEDS OUT COMPETED.
INCREASES A BENEFICIAL INSECTS
INSECT POPULATIONS AND I'VE
SEEN MY BEEKEEPERS COLONIES
FLOURISHING BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER THE ALMOND BLOOM. I
HAVEN'T EVEN TOUCHED ON THE
SOIL HEALTH BENEFITS SUCH AS
ADDING ORGANIC MATTER AND
NITROGEN FIXATION. LOOK AT
THESE PICTURES. THIS IS HABITAT
THESE ARE ECOSYSTEMS. WE CUT
OUR INSECTICIDE USED BY TWO
THIRDS AND STILL TURNED IN TOP
QUALITY NUTS BUT THIS IS NOT
WHERE WE ARE STOPPING WE ARE
COTINUING WITH PROVEN CULTURAL
PRACTICES LIKE ORCHARD
SANITATION. WHILE ALSO
EXPLORING STERILE INSECT
TECHNOLOGY TO PREVENT AND MEET
PASS PROBLEMS HEAD ON. RECALL
HELLO YOU CAN'T RECALL IT
BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT YET
BUT RECALL THE PITCHER OF THE
YOUNG TREES WITH NO WEEDS IN
THE MIDDLE DURING THE SUMMER
THAT LOOKS SO BARE. THE LOWER
SET OF PICTURES IS THAT SAME
BLOCK FROM EARLIER IN THE
SPRING WHICH WE UTILIZE WINTER
RAINS TO GROW COVER CROPS THEN
TILL NTO THE SOIL JUST THE TOP
THREE INCHES UP.THE PEAS AND
CHEST TIED MUSTARD RECOVERED IN
LADY BAGS OF NATIVE
POLLINATORS. AND PAULINE IN
CARBON FROM THE AIR THE WHOLE
TIME AS THEY GROW. SLIDE. OKAY
YOU SHOULD HAVE SEEN THAT ONE
BEFORE GO AHEAD AND. THERE IS
THAT BLOOD BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
HAVE WEEDS ON IT THAT WAS THE
SAME WHEN YOU SAW BEFORE. AND
ONE MORE. AND THERE IT IS TWO
MONTHS LATER STILL NO WEEDS
STILL NO HERBICIDE USED IN THE
CENTERS AND GROWING EVENLY AND
BEAUTIFULLY WITH TARGETED
FERTILIZER APPLICATION. OKAY GO
AHEAD. AND NOW WE COME TO OUR
LAST GOAL OF DUST REDUCTION
WHICH HAS PERHAPS BEEN THE MOST
DIFFICULT AND I WILL TELL YOU
WHY IT IS GOING TO REQUIRE
COLLABORATION ON A MASSIVE
SCALE BECAUSE IT WILL INVOLVE
CHANGING HOW WE DO THINGS FROM
BEGINNING TO END. IT WILL NOT
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT IT WILL BE
EXPENSIVE FOR EVERYONE TO
HARVEST OFF GROUND ORCHARDS
WILL HAVE TO BE MANAGED
DIFFERENTLY TO ACCOMMODATE NEW
EQUIPMENT ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
PROCESS THESE FOR DRYING THAT'S
WILL HAVE TO BE ENGINEERED AND
IMPLEMENTED ALL WILL STILL
TRYING TO GET EVERY NOT OUT OF
THE ORCHARD TO MAINTAIN ZERO
WASTE AND REDUCE PEST HABITAT.
THERE ALSO REMAIN THE QUESTION
OF HOW FARMERS AND HAULERS WILL
OF FOR THE TRANSITION THE
THINGS THAT MOST PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE BIGGEST MAYBE
HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS TO MAKE
THESE CHANGES AND THE RIPPLE
EFFECTS. FOR NOW MY BROTHER AND
I FOLLOW BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES CAREFULLY WATCHING
HOW WE MANAGE THE ORCHARD FLOOR.
I JUST OUR EQUIPMENT AND MAKE
OUR PASSES WE ALSO WILL
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN UPGRADING
THE DUST. BUT FULHAM
REPLACEMENT ISN'T ALWAYS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT CAN BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN US GETTING-PAID FOR A YEAR'S WORTH OF WORK
AND NOT GETTING PAID AT ALL.
COST SHARE GRANTS FOR NEW
EQUIPMENT FOR RETROFITS CAN
MAKE A HUGE DIFFERENCE TO
OPERATIONS OF ALL SIZES. WE
WILL REDUCE OUR DUST BUT WE
NIGHT WE MIGHT NOT QUITE REACH
50% BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
GOALS ARE MEANT TO BE HARD TO
REACH IF THEY WORK HARD THEY
WOULDN'T QUALIFY AS A GOAL. BUT
JUST IN SETTING THEM WE
INITIATE CHANGE. RIGHT. AND I
WANT TO CLOSE WITH A FEW THINGS
ILLUSTRATING HOW ARE GOALS
EMPHASIZE THAT SUSTAINABILITY
IS A JOURNEY NOT A DESTINATION
I ALSO PITCHER THE ALMOND
INDUSTRY AS A FOOD WEB WE ARE
DEEPLY INTERCONNECTED WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH INCLUDE OUR
LABOR FORCE THE HOLLERS AND THE
PROCESSORS THE UNIVERSITIES
WHERE RESEARCH IS CONDUCTED THE
BUSINESS AN ENGINE ENGINEERS
THAT DEVELOP OUR EQUIPMENT THE
COMPANIES THEY GIVE US CROP
PROTECTION AND THE TECH
INDUSTRY THAT ENABLES.
INNOVATION AND IF ANY FOOD WEB
WHEN ONE PART BECOMES WEAK THE
OTHERS SUFFER AS WELL.
IMBALANCE LEADS TO DYSFUNCTION
SO WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF EVERY PART OF OUR WEB BEING
SUPPORTED IN REMAINING HEALTHY.
ANOTHER THING TO UNDERSTAND IS
THAT EVERY PRACTICE DOES NOT
WORK FOR EVERY OPERATION
EVERYONE WILL HAVE THEIR OWN
UNIQUE COMBINATION OF WHAT GETS
THEM CLOSER TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GOALS. WHICH WE
MONITOR MONITOR IN OUR
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAM. IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE TRADE OFFS WERE MADE
SHOES AND ULTRA EFFICIENT
IRRIGATION SYSTEM THAT SAVES
WATER ND REDUCES HERBICIDE
USE. BUT ALSO REDUCES THE
BILITY TO HAVE A CROP COVER
CROP OUTSIDE OF THE RAINY
SEASON. IF WE HAVE WHAT.
ANOTHER MERMAID SHOES COVER
CROPS KNOWING EXTRA TRACTOR
HOURS WILL BE REQUIRED TO
MANAGE IT. THESE ARE EXAMPLES
OF THE DECISIONS WE MAKE EVERY
SINGLE DAY SMALL FARMS FACE
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES THAN
LARGER ONES. BUT WE ARE ALL
CHALLENGED. ONE THING WE DO
HAVE IN COMMON IS THAT EVERY
SINGLE ALMOND FARMER IN
CALIFORNIA HAS INVESTED
FINANCIALLY THROUGH THEIR CROP
ASSESSMENT IN THE RESEARCH IN
THE WORK BEING DONE TO CREATE
CHANGE. OUR INVESTMENT DOES NOT
STOP IT RESEARCH THAT CONTINUES
ON TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. WHICH ARE
THEN BROUGHT TO GROWERS AND PUT
TO USE WE ARE ALWAYS LOOKING TO
THE FUTURE. AND THAT IS THAT'S
THE ALMOND INDUSTRY AND NHL
THANK YOU. PUN INTENDED. THE
CHRISTINE REALLY APPRECIATE-
YOUR PRESENTATION- AND I'M SURE
THERE WILL BE SOME QUESTIONS
OKAY I DO I STAY HERE GO BACK
THERE- IF YOU GO BACK IT WOULD
BE. YEAH YOU KNOW. NO PROBABLY
NOT YEAH SO IF YOU GO BACK-
THAT WOULD BE GREAT SIX BUTTONS
THAT WILL GET MY DOG UP HERE.
SO OUR FINAL- SPEAKER AND
PRESENTER- ON THIS PANEL IS
CINEMA COUNTY DAIRY OPERATOR
DIED BERETTA- WHO IS ALSO HERE
WITH US IN THE HEARING ROOM
MISTER BERBER RED AND HIS
FAMILY OPERATE ORGANIC DAIRY
SOUTHWEST OF SANTA ROSA. I HAD
THE PROFILE I HAD THE- THE
PRIVILEGE IN JOINING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE AND VISITING. HIS
FARM IN HIS DAIRY I WAS VERY
IMPRESSED WITH HIS EFFORTS TO
PURSUE SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE
IN THAT OPERATION. I WAS ALSO
IMPRESSED WITH HIS COWS WHICH
DEFINITELY APPEARED TO BE AMONG
THE HAPPIEST I HAVE SEEN IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND SO
WITH THAT THE FLOOR IS YOURS
DOUG. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I FELT THAT- WHEN I WHEN I WAS
REACH OUT TO IN THE INVITE TO
COME OVER I FELT THAT THIS WAS
THE BEST THING TO DO IS TO COME
MEET PERSONALLY HERE AFTER YOU
SPENT THE TIME AT MY FARM-
LISTENING AND I DO APPRECIATE.
THE INVITATION- JUST QUICK
LITTLE OVERVIEW I KINDA CAME
WITH A LITTLE DIFFERENT- MAYBE
MESSAGE SINCE THE OTHER TWO
PRESENTERS I'M I'M GOING TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT I'VE WHAT ARE FORM IS DONE
OVER THE YEARS- WE MILK ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED CALS WE OWN FOR
WE ON ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
ACRES AND TWO RANCHES AND I
ALSO LEASE A HUNDRED AND FORTY
ACRES OF STATE OWNED.
MITIGATION LAND FOR ENDANGERED
SPECIES FROM CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT- AND- CDFW NOW IS A
DISINCENTIVE FOR SCHWAB SO- I
GUESS THAT WE NOT THREE- CAL'S
IN- TWO THOUSAND AND SIX WE'VE
MADE THE TRANSITION TO ORGANIC-
WE WERE CONVENTIONAL DAIRY. UP
UNTIL THEN AND JUST IN OUR AREA
WITH THE PASSION THAT WE HAVE
AND MOST OF THE DAIRIES IN OUR
AREA ABOUT 90% OF OUR ORGANIC.
WE HAVE A TEN TO GROW PASTURE
WHERE THE DAIRIES. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AS MISTER MATHIS
pABILITY TO GROW MORE OF THEIR
OWN FEED AND HAY AND THINGS
LIKE THAT BUT WE'RE ALL THE
SAME. DAIRY INDUSTRY I THINK
THAT'S ONE THING THAT. TOO MANY
PEOPLE TRY TO SEPARATE THE
ORGANIC IN THE CONVENTIONAL AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
CANNOT DO. IN THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY WE'RE ALL MEANT TO
PRODUCE. THE BEST QUALITY MILK
THAT WE CAN'T IS DEFEATED- FEET
ARE. OUR PEOPLE- SO AGAIN AND-
SIX WE WENT AHEAD AND
TRANSITION TO ORGANIC- I AM
THIRD GENERATION I HAVE TO MY
CHILDREN- MY OLDEST DAUGHTER MY
YOUNGEST SON ON THE FARM WITH
ME AND I ALSO AVE A NINE YEAR
OLD GRANDSON. THAT IS FALLING
HE'S PROBABLY BETTER THAN THAT
THE TWO OLDER KIDS RELEASE T.
HE COMES TO WORK EVERY DAY- BUT
YOU KNOW SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT. THAT WE'VE DONE IT
BREADED JERRY OVER THE YEARS-
MY GRANDFATHER WAS VERY
INNOVATIVE AND IN IN THE- LATE
MIDDLE SIXTIES. DECIDED THAT HE
SHOULD BUILD MANURE PONDS TO
CAPTURE THAT MANEUVER- SO WE
CAN PUT THAT BACK ON THE FIELD
THIS FERTILIZER THIS WAS PRIOR
TO THE CLEAN WATER ACT- SO MY
DAD AND HIM BUILT THOSE YOU
KNOW WITH THEIR OWN EQUIPMENT
WE ARE WE ARE VERY LUCKY THAT
WE HAVE. THE CLAY PAN THERE
THAT THAT WE CAN PRESERVE THOSE
THE BOTTOM THOSE PAWNS WITHOUT
LEAKAGE INTO THE WATER TABLE- I
WAS ALWAYS TAUGHT THAT. TO MILK
THE MEDICARE AT THE LAND COULD.
COULD HANDLE- AND THAT THAT
LAND WOULD GIVE BACK TO YOU
AND- MOVING THROUGH. OUR GRANTS
BE AROUND MY GRANDFATHER WHEN I
WAS YOUNGER AND THEN PARTNERS
WITH MY DAD FOR ABOUT TEN
YEARS. I FINALLY BOUGHT THE
BUSINESS OUT IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND RUN IT MYSELF. I'VE
ALWAYS LOOKED FOR PROGRAMS THAT
WERE OUT THERE. TO HELP THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY- IN THE EARLY
EIGHTIES WE DID A THREE
NINETEEN H. GRANT- THROUGH THE
WATER BOARD AND ACTUALLY WITH
THE IN CONJUNCTION WITH OUR
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
TO PUT A FERTIGATION SYSTEM AND
WE WERE ABLE TO PUT A- PUMP ON
ONE OF OUR MANY WERE PAWNS AND
WE- WE INJECT THAT MANY WERE
INTERROGATION SYSTEM. WE SAW A
HUGE INCREASE IN A PRODUCTION
OF OUR SILAGE FIELDS BY DOING
THAT THAT PLANT GETTING AT THE
RIGHT TIME- OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'VE DONE IS I WAS THE FIRST
DAIRY. IN THE UNITED STATES. TO
DO A NUTRIENT OFFSET PROJECT
FOR THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA- WE
HAVE BEEN A PARTNER WITH CITY
OF SANTA ROSA FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS UTILIZING THEIR RECLAIMED
WASTEWATER TO IRRIGATE. THEY
WERE RUNNING INTO SOME.
PROBLEMS WITH NITROGEN
PHOSPHOROUS WITH THE WATER
BOARD AND THEY CAME TO ME AND
THEY SPEND ABOUT A HUNDRED. AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS- ON A
PROJECT OF TAKING CATTLE
ACTUALLY CREATING A CONCRETE
WALKWAY. THROUGH AN AREA THAT
COULD POSSIBLY RUN OFF THE FARM
AND WE CHANGED TO MAN OR
MANAGEMENT- PRACTICES ALSO-
WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THE- THE
DIGEST ARE PROJECTS THAT WERE
BEING DONE IN THE VALLEY. WE
ALL KNEW IN OUR AREA THAT THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WOULDN'T
BENEFIT THE SMALLER DAIRIES- SO
BUNCH OF US KIND OF GOT
TOGETHER AND STARTED TALKING
ABOUT ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS AND WE MET.
PROBABLY FOR TWO OR THREE YEARS
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WOULD WORK-
I DO APPRECIATE- SECRETARY ROSS
FOR REACHING OUT AND REALLY
LISTENING TO THE GROUPS THAT
THAT CAME TO HER ABOUT THIS AND
I APPRECIATE THAT COMMITTEE FOR
MOVING FORWARD WITH THESE BUT-
IT HAS BEEN A HUGE HELP TO US
SO. WE HAVE AN AIR PROJECT- WE
ARE PROBABLY ABOUT FORTY FIVE
DAYS ABOUT AWAY FROM BEING
FINISHED- WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN-
INPUT AUTOMATIC SCRAPERS AND A
FREE STILLBORN. WHICH WILL THEN
GO TO A SCHOOL SMALL SUMP PUMP
THE PUMP THROUGH A SEPARATOR.
AND WE WILL SEPARATE THAT
MANEUVER AND REUSE IT IS
BETTING SO IT'S- IT'S GONNA
TAKE- VIA A LABOR SAVINGS FOR
US IT'S GOING TO BE. AN INPUT
SAVINGS WERE WE WERE BUYING
WASHED RIVER SAND- WILL BE ABLE
TO UTILIZE THAT MANEUVER BACK.
PLUS THE AMOUNT OF METHANE AND-
DIESEL THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
REDUCING CARBON GO AND- WITH
THAT MANURE I ALSO BE ABLE TO-
COMPOST SOME OF MY MEN WHO WERE
ON SITE. AND UTILIZE THAT BACK
ONTO OUR PROPERTY TO WHERE
WE'VE JUST SPREAD IT AS A US
DRIVE WITH A MAN WHO WERE- THAT
PROJECT HAS BEEN. SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN REALLY GREAT- IT
WAS TOUGH TO GET INTO. IT WAS-
I THINK IF I DIDN'T HAVE UC
EXTENSION FOR THE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
HAVE REALLY. GOT THE RIGHT
APPLICATION INTO TO RECEIVE
THAT GRANT- I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING MOVING FORWARD THAT
REALLY NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT I
HEARD- SECRETARY ROSS TALK
ABOUT THAT BUT- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE FARMING
COMMUNITY THAT NEEDS TO BE
AVAILABLE WHEN WE GO INTO THESE
GRANTS- THE TOUGHEST THINGS I
TOLD- SOMEONE RIVAS WHEN HE WAS
THERE IS. THE WAY THE MONEY IS
PAID OUT WE ARE ABLE TO- LET.
APPLY FOR MONEY BACK WITH
INVOICES QUARTERLY- IT'S BEEN
GREAT IF WE'VE HAD A BIG
EXPENDITURE THEY SAID GO AHEAD
AND SEND THE MEN BUT- I'M
BANKROLLING THE SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR PROJECT. I'VE
HAD TO TAKE OUT A LOAN I
ACTUALLY WENT INTO MY CREDIT
LINE AND SO I'M PAYING INTEREST
ON THAT AND- THE ONE THING I DO
HAVE TO- REALLY SAVES. THE LADY
AT- THAT I HAS BEEN WORKING ON
MY PROJECT HAS BEEN EXCEPTIONAL
THE SUPPORT THERE TO GET IT
BACK TO WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BEEN
GETTING OUR MONEY. BETWEEN
THREE TO FIVE WEEKS WHICH IT
WAS ORIGINALLY IT WAS FORTY
FIVE TO SIXTY DAYS- THE OTHER
PROJECT I HAVE GOING ON I WAS
ACCEPTED LAST YEAR FOR HEALTHY
SOILS PROJECT- THAT ONE HAS
BEEN. NOT THE WAY I REALLY
EXPECTED IT WE WERE TOLD WE
WOULD THAT WE- WERE ACCEPTED.
FOR FIVE MONTHS DOWN THE ROAD
BEFORE WE GOT PAPERWORK TO SIGN
STILL ANOTHER COUPLE WEEKS
BEFORE WE GOT THE OK TO MOVE
AHEAD AND THEN- YOU HAVE TO
HAVE THIS DONE BY THE END OF
THE YEAR. AND THIS WAS MID
NOVEMBER IF WE WOULD'VE HAD A-
THE WINTER IN SONOMA COUNTY
LIKE WE SHOULD OF THERE'S NO
WAY I WOULD HAVE GOT IT DONE
BUT WE GOT ON IT WE GOT OUR
SEED IN THE GROUND WE'VE GOT
OUR PICTURES MY DAUGHTER PUT
TOGETHER A TEN PAGE- REPORT
SENATE. AND THEY SAID WELL
THAT'S THAT'S NOT EXACTLY WE
WANT THIS IS WHAT WE WANT NOW
I'M HEARING THAT MAY NOT SEEN
IN MY MONEY FOR. UNTIL AFTER I
RAISE THEM THE GROUND. I'VE GOT
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OUT THERE SITTING IN SEAT
COSTING COMPARABLE COST RIGHT
NOW. SO THESE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE. TOUGH FOR THE FORMER- BUT
I STILL THINK THESE PROJECTS.
NEED TO HAPPEN AND OR AND YOU
KNOW I REALLY. THANK THE STATE
FOR REACHING OUT DOING THESE
THINGS- YOU KNOW ONE THING THAT
IN THE DAIRY INDUSTRY. THAT WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER OR THE DAIRY
WE ARE PRICE TAKERS WE DON'T
GET CENTER PRICE. PRICES SET BY
THE FEDERAL MARKETING ORDER SO
IT'S REALLY TOUGH WHEN.
LEGISLATORS SUCH AS YOURSELVES
AND AIR QUALITY BOARD WATER
BOARDS DECIDE TO BRING ON NEW
REGULATIONS WITH COSTS TO US.
OUR STATE WATER QUALITY BOARD.
10% INCREASE THIS YEAR ON A
DAIRY PERMITS FOR WHAT. BUT WE
DON'T KNOW WHY BUT ITS COST IS
10% MORE WE DON'T GET TO PASS
IT ON SO IT'S JUST GOING TO YOU
KNOW AS- AS JASON SAID IT'S
GETTING INTO OUR BOTTOM LINE- I
THINK ONE THING THAT. REALLY
NEEDS TO BE DONE. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD NEW REGULATIONS IS WE
NEED TO HAVE EVERYBODY AT THE
TABLE TOGETHER- COMPOST AS WE
HEARD IS YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
MAJOR. THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
PUT ON A GROUND FOR CARBON
SEQUESTERING THERE WAS A AN AIR
QUALITY BILL THAT GOT SHOT DOWN
FINALLY BUT GOING THROUGH THAT
WAS GOING TO REALLY AFFECT OUR
COMPOST FACILITIES. AND IF WE
CAN'T HAVE THOSE COMPOST
FACILITIES CLOSE HOW ARE WE
GOING TO GENERATE THAT COMPOST
TO BE ABLE TO PUT ON ALL THESE
LANDS. IT'S CRAZY TO HAUL
COMPOST FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
ANDERSON ON ACCOUNT OF THE
FOOTPRINT ALONE IN THE
TRUCKING. IS MORE THAN WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE STARTING AS
QUAESTOR SO I THINK THERE HAS
TO BE SOME SOME OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT. AS I SAID EARLIER I AM I
AM I ONE OF THOSE GUYS HAVE
ALWAYS LOOKED TO THE FUTURE
MAYBE I STICK MY NECK OUT YOU
KNOW A LITTLE BIT TOO FAR
SOMETIMES WHEN I GET INVOLVED
IN SOME OF THESE PROJECTS BUT-
I'VE BEEN YOU KNOW REALLY HAPPY
WITH WITH WHAT'S GOING ON- ONE
OTHER QUICK ONE WAS WHEN WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT FOR GRAZING
AND FIRE RESILIENCE- AS I SAID
I WOULD. REYES A HUNDRED FORTY
ACRES THAT I RENT FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HOW MANY
OF YOU HIRE A MANAGER TO MANAGE
THE LAND OR TO MANAGER PROJECT
AND ASKED THEM TO PAY YOU. THE
PROPERTY IS OWNED BY THE STATE.
IT'S MOSTLY MANAGED BY STATE ON
THE MANAGEMENT TOOL I SHOULD BE
AT LEAST GETTING IT FOR NOTHING
OR IF NOT GETTING PAID I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
HAVE TO LOOK AT. WITH THE
FARMING COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY IN
GRAZING- IS REACHING OUT TO
THOSE IN PAIN FOR THOSE TYPE OF
PRACTICES. IN SPACE CARBON
SEQUESTERED IT'S ALL THERE
WE'VE BEEN DOING THESE THINGS
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS. AND THE
ONLY OTHER WAY TO GO BACK IS GO
BACK TO TOWN AND START TEARING
HOUSES OUTPUT AND PASTURE AND
THINGS BACK AND WE KNOW WE
CAN'T DO THAT. SO REALLY WHEN
WE LOOK AT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
KEEP AGRICULTURE INVOLVED KEEP
AGRICULTURE. GROWING AND
PROFITABLE THERE HAS TO BE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
WE DO- TO HELP BACK CONTINUE TO
DO WHAT WE'RE DOING IF NOT DO
MORE- I. WE HAVE TRIED SOME NO
TILL SEEDING IT IS REALLY SEEM
TO WORK AND YOU KNOW ONE OF OUR
GOALS IS PROBABLY MOVING
FARTHER AWAY FROM TILL THE LAND
TO NO TILL FOR OUR SILAGE CROPS
PASTURE HAS REALLY SEEM TO WORK
OUT VERY WELL- IT'S JUST I
THINK. SOME OF IT IS THE OLD
SCHOOL GUYS- DON'T WANT TO
CHANGE TO THE NEW SCHOOL. BUT I
THINK IT'S THAT THE NUMBERS ARE
THERE AND THE AVAILABILITY AND
YOU KNOW AND THOSE THINGS ARE.
ARE ABLE TO BE DONE- I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY ABOUT ALL I
REALLY HAVE ON. ON THAT I THINK
MY THE BEST THING FOR ME IS
QUESTIONS AND THAT YOU KNOW
THAT US INTO THE OTHER PARTS OF
PANEL COULD COULD ANSWER
UNTESTED GOLD PALM REALLY
APPRECIATE PRESENTATION AND-
YOU KNOW- YOUR CANDID RESPONSES
TO. YOU KNOW YOUR EXPERIENCE
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT I REALLY
ENJOYED ABOUT MY VISIT TO- YOUR
DAIRY IS YOU'RE JUST A STRAIGHT
SHOOTER AND YOU KNOW YOU SPOKE
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO CERTAINLY
I THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR.
THE COMMITTEE TO YOU KNOW. HERE
THE EXPERIENCE OF THANK YOU
DOUG. AND SO WITH THAT OPEN IT
UP TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS. FOR MEMBERS
OF OUR PANEL AND YOU CAN STAY
THERE LIKE THAT YEAH. BYE SHE
MATHIS. THE FIRST OWNER THANK
YOU FOR. MAKING THE TRIP- I
KNOW ITS- IT'S A LOT HARDER
WHEN YOU'RE SMALL DAIRY VERSUS
BIG VERY WITH THOUSANDS
ACCOUNTS AND- A LOT OF PEOPLE
ASSUME THAT EVERYBODY'S ON THE
LARGE SCALE. AND DON'T SEE THE
DIFFERENT TPES OF THAT ARE OUT
THERE HAVING TO GO THROUGH THE
DRIVE PRACTICE AND KEEP
EVERYTHING ON THERE SO I
APPRECIATE YOU HIGHLIGHTING
THAT. TODAY BECAUSE IT IS A
SEPARATE PROCESS- IT WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE CONVERSATIONS AND
FIGHTS WE FED UP HERE FOR
YEARS- TRYING TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE- MY BIGGEST
QUESTION IN IN THIS FRANKLY IS
FOR ALL THE PANELISTS CAN YOU
ALL DIVE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
INTO THE- ADDED. ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS. FOR APPLYING FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT GRANTS AND EVERYTHING
THAT KEEPS COMING DOWN FROM THE
STATE BECAUSE I KNOW IT'S- IT'S
ONE THING TO HAVE FUNDING
AVAILABLE. BUT IT'S ANOTHER
THING TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO-
LIKE YOU'D MENTIONED GOING
THROUGH- DAVIS TO GET HELP WITH
IT BUT NOT EVERYBODY HAS THOSE
CAPABILITIES NOT EVERYBODY.
KNOWS HOW TO DO THAT- IN THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT COSTS IN THERE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IF YOU HAVE TO
STEP OUT. FROM RUNNING YOUR
DAIRY IN MANAGING THAT TO GO
SIT DOWN AND FILL OUT AN
APPLICATION. WHO'S GOING AROUND
THE FARM. AND SO IF YOU ALL
COULD SHARE ABOUT YOUR
EXPERIENCES WITH THAT- IT AND
I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM ALL THE
PANELISTS IF. TO THE CHAIR
ABSOLUTELY. BUT I THINK- YOU
KNOW THAT WAS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WAS VERY
LUCKY WITH- WE DO HAVE A NEW-
DAIRY SPECIALIST AND THREE UC
EXTENSION IN OUR AREA. SO WE
HAD BEEN A COUPLE MEETINGS AND
I TALKED ABOUT THE PROJECT THAT
I WAS THINKING ABOUT AND SHE
DID. STEP UP AND HELP ME THEY
ACTUALLY HAD SOME MONEY IN
THEIR BUDGET THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO- HELP THAT OUT- WE HAVE
A VERY ACTIVE- RCD. HELLO THREE
GROUPS IN SONOMA MARIN COUNTY
THREE RCTS THAT- YOU KNOW HAVE.
ALWAYS BEEN THERE FOR US BUT
THERE IS SOME COST AND YOU KNOW
THEY THEY HAVE TO PUT IT IN
THEIR BUDGET ALSO. SO- YOU KNOW
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT IN
THE GRAND IF THERE'S THE WAY
THAT YOU CAN THROW SOME YOU
KNOW TECHNICAL SUPPORT IN AT
GRANDPA. BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO
BE REAL CAREFUL THERE TOO
BECAUSE OUR OUR- TECHNICAL
GROUPS OUT THERE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO CHARGE YOU KNOW WAY
TOO MUCH MONEY TO DO THIS- CELL
BUT IT IS IT IS IT WAS A- VERY
I MEAN I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO COME UP WITH THE
REDUCTIONS. THAT WE WERE GOING
TO DO. BECAUSE I MEAN I HAVE A
HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION AND GO TO
SCHOOL AND HAVE ALL THAT YOU
KNOW. GO TO COLLEGE AND THIS
AND THAT BUT- WITH THEIR
ABILITY AND THEIR EXPERTISE IT
WAS REAL THAT WAS. MADE MY- MY
CHANCES OF YOU KNOW GETTING THE
GRANT A LOT BETTER SO I REALLY
THINK THOSE ARE THINGS. THAT
NEED TO BE. PART OF THESE
PROGRAMS THAT COME FROM THE
STATE BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT
OF SMALLER GROWERS IN OUR AREA.
THAT ARE GOING TO NEED THAT
JUST LIKE YOU SAID THEY'RE
DOING THE WORK THEIR SELVES.
THEY MAY EVEN BE. DOING THAT
YOU KNOW FROM. AFTER WORK AND
THEY'RE GONNA NEED TO GET OUT
THERE AND HARPER SAYS YOU KNOW
THE SPECIALTY CROPS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT I DID- I THOUGHT THAT
WAS GREAT THAT SECRETARY ROSS
TALKED ABOUT IT. YOU KNOW FOR.
KIND OF TRICKLING DOWN INTO THE
INTO THE SPECIALTY CROPS ALSO.
pEXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN A NEW
TOUCH ON IT. IT'S WE SEEM TO
FORGET. UP HERE UNDER THE DOME
IN SACRAMENTO ABOUT THE
SMALLER. FAMILY FARMER. AND
WHAT THOSE EXPERIENCES ARE LIKE
BECAUSE WE THINK OF. YOU KNOWS
AGAS IS BEING. A GIANT NORMAN
NUMIS- YOU KNOW COMMODITY-
VERSUS ALL THE FAMILY FARMS
THAT HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR
GENERATION AFTER GENERATION AND
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE- THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR SHARING I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE GET TO ALL THE
PANELISTS AND NOT. SHOOT TOO
MUCH TIME. I WANTED TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT FAMILY FARMERS
AND SMALL FARMS. A LOT OF WHAT
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE TODAY IS A
LOT OF THE SMALL FARMS ARE
BEING HANDED DOWN. BUT THEY'RE
REALLY NOT MAKING MANY AND
TRUTHFULLY A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW THAT HAVE SMALL
ALMOND OPERATIONS. THEY HAVE
SIDE JOBS THAT ACTUALLY BE THE
FAMILY AND THE THING IS THEY
WANT TO KEEP THAT THAT LAND
THAT'S A PART OF THE FAMILY. SO
KEEP IT EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT
REALLY PAYING THE BILLS- I MEAN
LOOK AT JASON YES A PSYCHIC. SO
THE- OKAY. I WANNA HEAR FROM
JASON TO YEAH I MEAN IF YOU
COULD SHARE WITH US THE- JUST
THE PROCESS THAT YOU HAD TO GO
THROUGH IN IN A PLAYOFF. I OR
OR YOU'RE YOU KNOW OF OTHER
FRIENDS THEY THEY YOU FARM WITH
A I KNOW A HEALTHY SOILS WHEN
MY COUSIN TO THE HEALTHY SOILS
ONE AND IT WAS. I MEAN.
BASICALLY THAT WAS SOMEBODY'S
JOB. TO ACTUALLY PUT THAT GRANT
THAT THE LARGER YOU ARE THE
OPERATION THE MORE RESOURCES
YOU HAVE. TO ACTUALLY PUT THAT
APPLICATION TOGETHER I'M- I'M
STILL GOING TO TRY AND DO IT
BUT YES IT'S VERY TIME
CONSUMING BECAUSE IT'S- AT YOU
KNOW. I NEED TO BE ON THE
TRACTOR ALL DAY WORKING OR
DOING WHATEVER IT IS I'M DOING
THAT DAY IN THE FIELD. SO
THAT'S WHAT MY NIGHTS ARE SPENT
DOING. YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW I
HAVE A LOT GOING ON. BUT I AM
ABLE TO GET TO THAT BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY IT IS REALLY HARD.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK THEIR
RESOURCES ONE THOUGH BOARD WENT
FOR- THE WHOLE ORCHARD
RECYCLING THAT WAS A BAD THAT
ONE WAS DEFINITELY DO IT WILL
BE NICE IF THEY WERE MORE LIKE
THAT ONE. SO MAYBE IT MAYBE USE
THAT ONE AS A MODEL. I MEAN IN
THE SMALL GUYS THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO NEED IT THE MOST THEY
REALLY ARE. ONE MORE. IS JASON
STONE IS THAT ME YEP- YEAH SO I
HAVE A SIDE JOB AS WELL- AND TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU. I HAD I
KNOWN- YEAH I GUESS THE
ECONOMIC PRESSURES OF
OPERATING- FRUIT PRODUCTION I
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN TOO
SCARED TO GET INVOLVED BUT I
JUMPED IN BECAUSE IT WAS
ROMANTIC AND ALSO BECAUSE THE
TREES WERE ALREADY HERE WHEN I
MOVED IN SO I STARTED TO
INTERACT WITH THE TREES AND
WHICH- WHICH THEN MADE ME.
QUESTION HOW DO THE SMALL FARMS
DO IT YOU KNOW IF I'M GOING
ORGANIC AND I HAVE MY
CERTIFICATIONS AT MY FOOD AND
SAFETY I'M WORKING WITH THE-
NATURAL- CONSERVATION- EFFORTS.
IT IS SO BUSY AND I'M PUTTING
SO MUCH INPUT INTO IT AND
THERE'S LITTLE RETURN- IT
FORCED ME TO LOOKING TO
SPECIALTY CROPS INTO
DIVERSIFIED BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THE MY MENTOR FARMERS OUT HERE
TOLD ME TO DO- THEY SAID IF YOU
REALLY WANT TO SURVIVE YOU. YOU
YOU NEED TO DIVERSIFY AND-
THINK OF THIS IN IN THE BIG
PICTURE- SO LIKE I SAID I
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN HAD I
KNOWN HOW HOW VERY VERY
CHALLENGING THIS IS A FIGHT
WOULD HAVE DONE IT YET I'M SO
GLAD I DID BECAUSE NOW I FEEL
LIKE WE CAN SERVE AS A MODEL
AND HOPEFULLY IN ROLE MORE
YOUNG PEOPLE INTO AGRICULTURE.
IS WHAT I'VE SEEN ESPECIALLY
WITH A SMALL FAMILY FARMS IN MY
AREA IS THAT THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH YOUNG PEOPLE TO REPLACE
THE OLDER FARMERS WHO WILL BE
RETIRING THIS GENERATION SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE AND SENATE
THERE NEED TO BE LAND THERE
NEEDS TO BE- RETURN ON THE
CROP- JUST. MORE ENCOURAGING-
PROGRAMS I AM VERY LUCKY THAT I
DON'T HAVE TO RELY ON GRANTS
AND BANK LOANS TO DO THIS BUT-
THIS YEAR WAS REALLY HARD
BECAUSE ALL OF MY OTHER SIDE
GIGS WERE CANCELLED YOU KNOW AS
AS WE MANY OF US MANY OF US
HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE- SO I
LOOKED I LOOKED EVEN CLOSER AT
MY FRUIT PRODUCTION AND HOW WE
COULD. FIND MORE BENEFITS IN IN
BEING HERE. COULD I JUST GIVE
YOU ONE QUICK YEAH THE THREE OF
US OF KIND OF TALK ABOUT SMALL
FARMS AND AS I MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THAT IN YOUR DISTRICT WE
HAVE A LOT OF A LOT OF LARGE
DAIRIES. I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY
EASIER FOR THEM. THEN IT IS FOR
THE SMALL FOR. THEM THEY'RE
LOOKING AT LARGER NUMBERS
THEY'RE LOOKING AT LARGER
REDUCTIONS. CAN'T WE CAN'T.
FORGET ABOUT IT SHOULD BE THERE
IS THERE YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
THOSE BIG REDUCTIONS. THAT WE
NEED IS A STATE IN SOME OF OUR
OR BIGGER. EXACTLY THREE
THOUSAND G. I'M JUST TELLING
THEIR USERS ARE STILL. HAND
SOMETHING THAT. IS YOU KNOW
REALLY IT'S A LOT SIMILAR
THROUGHOUT. THE STATE JUST A
DIFFERENT SCALE. AND I HAD IN
THE CAN'T WE CAN'T CURE ALL
THESE THINGS TO THE SMALL FORM
IT'S GREAT. THAT THE SMALL THAT
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR THE SMALL
FARMS AND MAYBE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A LITTLE MORE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT ON- BUT- YOU KNOW WE
CAN'T FORGET ABOUT THE LARGER
THE DAIRY INDUSTRY ITSELF. NO
AT ABSOLUTELY I THINK- WHAT ONE
OF THE THINGS IS LIKE JASON
MENTIONED I MEAN YOU YOU KNOW
GOING TO. DO ON A FARM OR A
RANCH THINKING YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SPEND 80% OF YOUR TIME
DOING ADMINISTRATIVE WORK.
THANK YOU. EITHER WE HAVE A
QUESTION FOR SOME THE MEMBER
WOULD. YEAH AND ACTUALLY I
PROBABLY SOMETHING FOR
EVERYBODY HERE- FIRST FALL.
MISTER BRADLEY THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR THE PRACTICES THAT YOU'RE
OING AND THE PERSEVERANCE AND-
THAT YOU DO I KNOW- FROM
MEETING WITH OTHER DAIRY AND
DAIRY MEN AND THEIR- PEOPLE
OVER THE YEARS THAT THAT THAT
IT'S TOUGH IT'S REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT. I WAS CURIOUS I AM
VERY CURIOUS ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU BROUGHT UP WAS THE FACT
THAT- YOU YOU PAY THE STATE TO
GRAZE. THEIR LAND AND EDWARDS
YOU'RE PAYING FOR THE PRIVILEGE
OF MANAGEMENT ROUGHLY WHAT IS
THE COST ON THAT DO YOU HAVE.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A TODAY THAT'S FINE
I'M BUT RIGHT HERE IN ACTUALLY
IT THAT THE TOUGHEST PART ABOUT
THAT WAS- ORIGINALLY WHEN IT
WHEN IT STARTED I HAD A-
GRAYSON AGREEMENT WITH THEM.
AND SOMETHING WENT. HOW KATHY
WALTERS HERE AT THE STATE AND-
WE HAD TO PUT IT ALL OUT TO
BID. SO HERE I AM A DERRY MAN
THEY HAD TO GO THROUGH THE BID
PROCESS OF A STATE BID PROCESS.
GO THROUGH WALKING THROUGH. I
THINK THE APPLICATION WAS
TWENTY. ABOUT TWENTY PAGES.
THREE MILLION DOLLAR LIABILITY
INSURANCE YOU KNOW I MEAN IT
COPIES SO THERE'S- SO WHEN I
DID IT WHERE I CAME OUT. OKAY
WAS BECAUSE I WAS THE ONLY ONE.
IN THE WATER SO I DID IT PRETTY
CHEAP. BUT YOU KNOW I THINK
SOME OF IT'S PROBABLY. IN THAT.
FIFTY THE FIFTY TO SIXTY
DOLLARS PER HEAD OF ANIMALYOU
KNOW ON THAT ACRE SO YOU USE I
MEAN SO SOMEWHERE IN. SOMEWHERE
PRO I MEAN I'M THE FOR RITUAL
YOU FIRST YEAR THAT I DID IT-
THE FIRST ONE I WENT THROUGH I
WAS PAY AND- FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE YEAR FOR A
HUNDRED FORTY ACRES. BUT I ONLY
GET THAT. FROM FEBRUARY THROUGH
JUNE BECAUSE OF THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES I CAN ONLY GRAYSON
CERTAIN TIMES. SO YOU KNOW IT
IT IT ALL DEPENDS ON WHO SHOWS
UP TO BED THAT THAT WAY AND-
THE LIKE SAID THOSE THE SECOND
ROUND THROUGH THERE WAS NOBODY
ELSE OF THE WACHTER SO I KNEW I
WAS THE ONLY ONE VIDEO THEY DID
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SAY NO
BUT THEY THEY ACCEPTED AND I
HAVE IT DOWN TO RIGHT NOW I
THINK I'M PAYING RIGHT AROUND A
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THAT LAND
FOR YOU KNOW I GET FOR ABOUT
FOUR MONTHS T'S A THREE YEAR.
IT'S A THREE YEAR LEASE I HAVE
TO LET HIM KNOW TWO HUNDRED
SOMETHING DAYS PRIOR AND I HAVE
TWO ONE YEAR OPTIONS. BUT IT IS
YOU KNOW IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT'S KIND OF
CUMBERSOME TO GO THROUGH. IF
AND- THE YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME
OF THESE PLACES HAVE. NO CROWDS
NO INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY HAVE
WATER. WE HAVE IT THERE SEVENTY
TWO ACRES. THAT HAS BEEN
SITTING THERE NOW FOR. OVER TEN
YEARS NOTHING'S BEEN ON IT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO WATER. AND
THEY HAD A FARMER THAT WAS
GRAYSON AT ALL I HAD TO DO WAS
OPEN THE GATE. WHEN HE WHEN
ORGANIC THE STATE WOULD NOT LET
THAT GET THAT GROUND BE
CERTIFIED ORGANIC SO NOW IT'S
CITY. SO THOSE ARE YOU KNOW
THERE'S SOME CHALLENGES IN IT
BUT- YOU KNOW JUST TO ME IT'S
REALLY TOUGH WHEN YOU HAVE TO
PAY FOR SOMETHING THAT. HAS
BEEN GIFTED TO THE STATE THERE
WAS AN ENDOWMENT FUND WITH
THESE MITIGATION BANKS. AND NOW
AS I LEE SAID I HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF THE FENCES BECAUSE THEN
DOWN THE MONEY'S GONE. WHERE
DID IT GO ON THE MATTER FIVE
YEARS BUT IT'S GONE- I'M ALSO
STRUCK BY- LISTENING TO YOU
TALK AND- THE STRUCK BY THE
DIFFERENCES. I MEAN THERE
THERE'S CLEAR DIFFERENCE WITH
AND I AM- AGRICULTURE AND
ALMONDS AND WHAT CHASENS DOING
VERY VERY DIFFERENT YEAH A LOT
OF INTERACTION WITH A LOT OF
THE CITY SAME THE SAME
AGENCIES. AND YOU KNOW AND- AND
ALL I'LL JUST SAY- I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS WHERE YOU
YOU KNOW YOU CAN GET FREE
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE YOU
HAVE TO DO THE WORK AND APPLY
TO GET IT YOU KNOW GET THE
MONEY BACK- YOU'RE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE NOT- IT'S-
AND THAT MAKES IT. THAT MAKES
IT EVEN MORE CHALLENGING WE SEE
THAT WITH THAT STATION
MANAGEMENT FORESTRY WHERE
PEOPLE THE SEAFOOD- PROGRAM
WHERE YOU YOU DO THE WORK AND
THEN YOU CAN YOU APPLY TO GET
THE MONEY BACK IT MIGHT BE
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX MONTHS AND-
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THAT CASH YOU
YOU TO PUT OUT THE FIRST PLACE
YOU CAN'T DO IT SO. SO YOU HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT TO LINES
OF CREDIT SO I APPLAUD YOU. FOR
THE EXTRA STEPS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO- IN ADDITION TO THE
KIND OF WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
SO- BUT I CAN SEE THAT IT'S
CHALLENGING AND IN MY DISTRICT-
MOST OF THE FARMS ARE SMALL
FARMS WITH THEIR DAIRIES OR- A
CATTLE OR OR OTHER KINDS OF
CROPS THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
ALMOST ALL SMALL ALL SMALL AND
SO- YOU KNOW IT'S CHALLENGE.
IT'S CHALLENGING OUT THERE SO-
I DO QUESTION FOR JASON IF HE'S
IF HE'S STILL THERE. I HOPE WE
GET RUN OFF TO A GIG. BUT I
WOULDN'T BLAME YOU IF YOU DID-
EXTRA YET. SO I AM- ABOUT THE
CHOICE OF CROPS THAT YOU DID I
MEAN YOU'VE GOT YOU'VE GOT YOU
START WITH AVOCADOS NOW YOU'RE
GROWING COFFEE- AND BANANAS- IS
THE WHAT IS THAT WHEN YOU SEEN
AS THE CO BENEFITS OF THAT
COMBINATION OF CROPS TO YOUR TO
YOUR LAND- AND WHAT DOES THAT
DO FOR LIKE WATER CONSUMPTION
AND WAS IT. WAS IT LOOKED LIKE
FROM YOU'VE SEEN THIS NOW
BECAUSE YOU'VE YOU'VE LIVED IT
WOULDN'T WOULDN'T WHAT DO YOU
SEE AS THE DIFFERENCES- VERT
THEN VERSUS NOW. WELL WE'RE
STILL SEEING- MORE CROP
PRODUCTION WITH NOT THAT MUCH
EXTRA INPUT IN WATER AND EVEN
LABOR BECAUSE OP ALWAYS REQUIRE
FEEDING. OUR SEASONALLY AND
PRUNING YEARLY WHICH LEFT US A
LOT OF TIME- TRY PRIOR TO
HAVING THIS SORT OF AGRO FOREST
IS VERY DIVERSE AND DANCE
LANDSCAPE- I COULD AFFORD TO BE
MORE OF AN ABSENTEE FARMER AS
MANY GENTLEMAN FARMS AND SMALL
FARM FAMILY FARMS CAN DO- BUT I
WANTED TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE IN
IN BETWEEN ALL OF THE AVOCADO
TREES. IS A RELATIVELY LARGE
AMOUNT OF REAL ESTATE SO WE- I
CHOSE THE SPECIALTY CROPS OF
COFFEE AND BANANAS- FOR THE
LOCAL ASPECT BECAUSE COFFEE.
HAS NEVER BEEN GROWN ON THE
MAINLAND UNITED STATES BEFORE
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN AN IMPORTANT
SO I WANTED TO ENCOURAGE AND
PROMOTE LOCAL. PRODUCE AND
BANANAS THE SAME WAY ARE. YOU
WE JUST WE CAN'T BY LOCAL
BANANA AT THE GROCERY STORE SO
I WANTED TO ADD SOME MORE LOCAL
VALUE TO RIGHT HERE AND REDUCE.
I WOULD SAY MY CARBON FOOTPRINT
IN MINE IMPORTING OF COFFEE AND
BANANAS LET'S SAY. SO ADDING IT
INTO OUR PROGRAM IT ALLOWED TO-
MY STAFF WHO WHO'S HERE TO JUST
CONTINUE TO FLY ME LABOR IS
PROBABLY THE MOST EXPENSIVE
THING THAT HAS CHANGED- BUT-
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS SO DENSE
AND KIND OF SHARING THE
IRRIGATION SYSTEM- WE'RE NOT
USING THAT MUCH MORE WATER IN
YET WE HAVE. FOUR THOUSAND MORE
TREES THAN WE STARTED WITH- SO
THEY WERE REALLY A LOT OF
BENEFITS- WE HAD SOME AREAS
THAT HAD SOME EROSION PROBLEMS
PRIOR TO OUR MORE AGGRESSIVE
PLANTING AND NOW WE'RE MORE OF
A SPONGE BECAUSE AS THE AS IT
RAINS WE CAN COLLECT THAT WATER.
SO ARE I FEEL LIKE OUR
ENVIRONMENT HAS DEFINITELY
CHANGED THE MICRO CLIMATES ON
OUR VARIOUS LOPES FROM THE TOP
TO THE TO THE LOWER MEADOW. ALL
OF THOSE. HAVE CHANGED IN WAYS
BECAUSE OF THE MORE VEGETATION
THAT WE'VE ADDED. THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S IT IS A
SMALL WORLD MY SON WORKS FOR
FRENCH. HE MIDDLE THE MIDDLE
SOME OF YOUR COFFEE YESTERDAY
WONDERFUL HELLO IT'S A VERY
SMALL WORLD AND- HE'S A BIG
HE'S A BIG FAN OF YOUR COFFEE I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT YU MUSIC
BECAUSE I YOU KNOW I GOT TO ASK
ABOUT THAT BUT- BUT HE'S A BIG
FAN OF YOUR COFFEE. I THINK IT
WILL. BEGIN IN COFFEE SHOPS SO
I'VE I'VE HAD A LOVE A COPY FOR
A LONG TIME. THANK YOU THANK
YOU HEY JASON- YOU. I WOULD I
AT THE CHEMICAL ON THE TWO ARE
YOUR RANCH YOU ALSO HAD- A
COVER CROP. RIGHT YES- AND
WE'VE DONE THAT WE'VE BEEN
EDUCATING OURSELVES IN
BENEFICIAL WEEKS BASICALLY YOU
KNOW WE HAVE CONVENTIONAL FARMS
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET THAT
WILL COME AND SPRAYED AROUND UP
ONCE OR TWICE A YEAR SO THEY
HAVE NO REASON THEY DON'T HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THAT BUT THERE ARE
SO MANY BENEFICIAL- NATURALLY
OCCURRING WEEDS LIKE STINGING
NETTLE AND- FOR EXAMPLE AND
WE'VE- ALSO GONE AN EXTRA MILE
TO. I SEE. A RED CLOVER AND-
AND VARIOUS SPECIES OF COVER
CROPS THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
DOMINATE THE WEEDS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
PULLING. AND IT JUST CONTINUES
TO ADD VEGETATION TO. THE SOIL
WHICH DOES GO HAND IN HAND ALSO
WE'LL ALL GROUND SHOULD HAVE
VEGETATION. ON IT COVER CROP OR
PERENNIAL TREE IT SHOULD NEVER
BE LEFT FALLOW FOR TOO LONG SO
WE'VE WE'VE ALSO BEEN
EXPERIMENTING WITH THAT. IT'S
GOING WELL. THAT'S GREAT- I
APPRECIATE YOU EXPLAIN THAT
THANK YOU- I KNOW THERE WAS- A
QUESTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
BELBUCA. THANK MISTER CHAIRMAN-
THIS IS MORE COMMON A JUST I.
SETBACK YOUR AND JUST LISTEN TO
ALL THREE OF YOU GUYS YOU GUYS
ARE COMING FROM ALL DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA AND I
APPRECIATE- YOUR PRESENTATION-
ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW HEARING
THAT YOUR YOUR YOUR KIDS ARE
TAKING ON THE NEXT GENERATION.
AND THAT'S ONE THING I HEAR
MORE BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
AROUND ASK FOR A LONG TIME YOU
KNOW- NEVER EVER HAVE I BEEN
HEARING THAT MORE THAT FOLKS
ARE LIKE. AWESOME GIVEN THE SAP
YOU KNOW I JUST CAN'T DO IT
ANYMORE YOU KNOW AND IT'S- THE
COST IS TOO EXPENSIVE AND- AND
I HATE IT WHEN YOU KNOW ANOTHER
FARMER WILL GIVE IT TO. A
DEVELOPER RIGHT BECAUSE HERE WE
ARE TRYING TO PROTECT THE GREEN
BELT WE'RE TRYING TO. CREATE
THE NEXT AG FOLKS AS MY BEEN A
BIG SUPPORTER OF THE MAG
VENTURE IN OUR IN OUR DISTRICT
AND SUPPORTING THAT- YEAH
THERE'S A PRISON THAT. IS THAT
SHUT DOWN THAT THEY HAVEN'T
TAG- FACILITY THEY WERE TRYING
TO EVEN PROTECT THAT RIGHT SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME TYPE OF
A- VOCATIONAL TRAINING THERE
FOR THE FOR THE NEXT- AG.
COMMUNITY. MIKE IT IS NOT A
QUESTION I'M JUST AND JUST AS I
WAS SITTING HERE THINKING THAT
MY STAFF THAT LITERALLY IN THE
DISTRICT HAS LIKE ALL HANDS ON
DECK WHEN IT COMES TO EDT H.
ISSUES AND OUR OUR- BUSINESS
GRANTS RIGHT. AND WHAT I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
WHEN WE WERE LIVE IN AND
LISTENING TO SOME OF THE
RECIPIENTS THAT RECEIVED IT.
BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN FOLKS THAT
RECEIVED THE GRAPH. AND SAY HEY
YOU KNOW. MANY TIMES HAVE I
APPLIED FOR A GRANT. IN AND
ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO GET IT BECAUSE IT'S IT
ALMOST TAKES ABOUT SCIENCE TO
GET THROUGH THIS YOU KNOW SOME
PEOPLE JUST BAIL OR TO SAY
FORGET AND I CAN EVEN DO THIS.
BUT PER. RUN KNEES THE GOVERNOR
REALLY DID YOU KNOW HIT A HOME
RUN BECAUSE HE HE MADE IT
SIMPLE HE MADE IT EASIER HE
MADE IT. SO THAT THAT THAT
FOLKS. ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
TIMES THAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH
MADE IT EASIER SAID BECAUSE YOU
GUYS HAVE A LOT OF STRESS ON
YOU. YOU KNOW YOU GUYS ARE
TRYING TO ALWAYS FIGURE OUT.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE- YOU
KNOW THE SCREWBALL THEY WERE
TRYING TO THROW DO YOU GUYS YOU
KNOW TRYING TO FIGURE HOW YOU
GUYS CAN HIT THAT. AND- YOU
KNOW. I THINK THAT WE'RE JUST
WE SHOULD JUST BE THROWING YOU
JUST A STRAIGHT BALL YOU KNOW
DOWN THE LINE SO THAT YOU GUYS
CAN REALLY SEE THIS AND I. YOU
KNOW AS I SIT HERE AND I THINK
ABOUT WHEN MY STUFF TO DO IN
OUR COMMUNITY I THINK THAT.
YOUR HUMONGOUS PART YOU KNOW OF
ART OF OUR ECONOMY. YOU KNOW
THREE OUT OF EVERY FIVE JOBS
ARE AG RELATED. YOU KNOW AND I
KEEP SAYING THAT BUT I KEEP
THINKING THAT. YOU KNOW ARE
THOSE STATISTICS CORRECT I MEAN
ARE THERE STATISTICS TRYING TO
GO DOWN. AND I JUST WANTED TO
THE COMMENT WAS JUST SAYING
THANK YOU GUYS FOR ALL FOR
BEING HERE BECAUSE- YOU KNOW
WITHOUT YOUR SAY SO WITHOUT
YOUR- YOU'RE COMING HERE. TO I
SEE PET. YOU EDUCATE US OF WHAT
YOU GUYS ARE GOING THROUGH- IS
REASON WHY YOU KNOW ALL OF US
HERE. ARE ARE YOU KNOW. ON THIS
COMMITTEE TO TRY TO LISTEN AND
DO WHAT'S BEST SO. I JUST WANNA
SAY THANK YOU GUYS THANK YOU
GUYS FOR TAKING THE TIME THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU SOME
NUMBERS TO BE ABLE TO OUR- SOME
MEMBER LEVINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- I REALLY
ENJOYED HEARING JASON'S STORY-
PARTICULARLY. BECAUSE I THINK
THE PERCEPTION IS PEOPLE CAN MY
GOING TO FARMING PARTICULAR
THEIR SUCCESS THE SUCCESSFUL IN
ONE INDUSTRY AND DO IT MAYBE
FOR FUN AND NOT WITH A BUSINESS
MENTALITY OF. ONE HOW DO YOU DO
DO SOME WITH A BOTTOM LINE BUT
ALSO. CO BENEFITS AS WELL AND
THE NEED FOR- FOR HAVING
ALTERNATIVE REVENUE STREAMS
THANK THAT'S A FASCINATING
ISSUE FOR US TO DEAL WITH AND
THE RISK THAT YOU TOOK IN.
THINKING MAYBE WE CAN HAVE A GO
OUT OF BANANAS AND WE CAN'T
HAVE A GO AND IT COULD BE A
MARKET. FOR COFFEE AND- YOU
KNOW QUOTE WHAT'S THAT
RECEPTION BEEN LIKE AS YOU'RE
INTRODUCING WHAT REALLY IS IF
YOU SET UP A FIRST TIME CROP IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS THIS WILL.
DESIRE TO HAVE. SOMETHING LOCAL
IS A STRONG ONE- FOR SO MANY OF
US IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT.
ENOUGH OR DO YOU ALSO FIND. YOU
KNOW THE TOUR ARE A IS GOOD
ENOUGH AND STRONG ENOUGH FOR
COFFEE AND YOU KNOW THAT
THERE'S A QUALITY. OF COURSE
YOU'RE GONNA SAY YOU'RE YOURS
IS THE FINEST COFFEE IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S THE ONLY ONE
BUT- YOU KNOW IT R. D. ARE YOU
FINDING THE QUALITY OF THE
PRODUCT IT THAT IT'S GETTING
ACCEPTED IN A WAY THAT THAT YOU
AND HOPED IS INTRODUCING THIS
NEW. CROP TO THE STATE THE DOES
THAT HAVE BARRIERS- DITCHED HOW
TO DESCRIBE WHAT THAT
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN LIKE. YEAH
CALIFORNIA HAS GREATER WORK FOR
COFFEE AND THE REASON IT'S
NEVER BEEN GROWN HERE IS REALLY
THE MARKET BECAUSE COFFEE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN- THE BOTTOMLESS
CUP. FREE REFILLS CETERA AND-
OUR OUR LABOR LABOR COSTS AND
WATER COSTS- JUST OUTWEIGH YOU
KNOW THE ABILITY TO DO THAT SO-
BUT LUCKILY NOW THERE'S A
pMORE ENTHUSIASM FOR COFFEE AS
WELL AS LOCAL COFFEE AND LOCAL
PRODUCE SO THEY THEY GO WELL
TOGETHER. BECAUSE THE COFFEE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA STILL SO
YOUNG THERE'S REALLY NOT ENOUGH
OF IT YET TO FILL THE DEMAND
WHICH MAKES THE COFFEE PRICES
ALSO VERY EXPENSIVE RECOVERING
LABOR AND WATER OF COURSE BUT
WE'RE ALSO WE HAVE A VERY RARE
PRODUCT AND SO IT'S VERY
EXCITING RIGHT NOW AND I THINK
THE GOAL. IS TO ENROLL MORE
MORE FARMERS INTO THE COFFEE
INDUSTRY- IS LOOKING AT IT LIKE
WINE WAS FIFTY YEARS AGO HERE
IN CALIFORNIA- THE MORE FARMS
WE HAVE PRODUCING COFFEE
EVENTUALLY THAT PRICE WILL COME
DOWN IN MORE MARK- COFFEE
SHOPS. AND CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WILL BE ABLE TO ENJOY A
CALIFORNIA GROWN COFFEE BUT
RIGHT NOW IT'S STILL SO YOUNG
AND IT'S SUCH A SPECIALTY CROP.
THAT IT IS VERY VERY EXPENSIVE
COFFEE IT'S- BY IT'S FOR. THE
SPECIALTY COFFEE CONNOISSEUR AT
THIS POINT- BUT YES THE
ENVIRONMENT CAN SUPPORT IT-
CALIFORNIA'S LEADER IN AG
ANYTHING WE GET OUR HANDS ON
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA DO WELL
WITH IT. SO FAR COFFEES TASTED
DELICIOUS. YEAH I WITH THAT I.
WE WE'VE GOT. YES I REPRESENT
MARIN WE'VE GOT EQUATOR- JOHN
WEAVER THE FORMER MASTRO STIR
OF PETEN THEY BOTH INTRODUCED
ME INTO HOW TO TASTE COFFEE AND
IT JUST KIND OF BLEW ME AWAY I
DON'T THINK MOST PEOPLE REALLY
THINK ABOUT HOW YOU CAN PICK UP
THE DIFFERENT FLAVORS IN COFFEE
BEANS SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
TRYING TO WORSE UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS FOR THE OTHER
PANELISTS IF THE TOURNAMENT.
YEAH I THINK YOU ON SO FOR
DOUG- YOU KNOW IN IN THE NORTH
BAY WE WENT. IN ON WE BEING YOU
KNOW THE OIL ALL OF OUR FARMERS
IN IN DERRY MAN- AND DIRTY
PEOPLE- TO SUSTAINABILITY. VERY
EARLY HOW YOU TALK ABOUT BEING
THE FIRST IN CINEMA FOR ORGANIC
BUT A LOT OF US. A LOT OF. US
IN THE NORTH BAY TO SWITCH
OVER- PROBABLY PROCEEDING. AS
YOU DID MUCH OF THE REST OF THE
STATE AND EVEN THE NATION. WHAT
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE OTHER.
SUSTAINABILITY MEASURES THAT
YOU'VE ENGAGED IN. YOU TALK A
LITTLE ABOUT SCALE EVERYONE HAS
CHALLENGES NO MATTER THE SCALE
THAT YOU'RE AT- WHAT THE
CHALLENGES ARE EVEN SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT MAKE YOUR YOUR
ENTRY POINT EASIER. BECAUSE OF
SCALE OR EVEN REPEAT THE REGION
THAT YOU COME FROM. I THINK YOU
KNOW. ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
KNOW THE BIGGEST ONE IS
PROBABLY WATER QUALITY YEAH-
THAT IS PROBABLY THE TOUGHEST
ONE. FROM THAT SCALE SIDE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THE STATE WATER QUALITY BOARD
LOOKS AT. THE THEY SEE ALL
THEIR USES THE SAME. CENTRAL
VALLEY HAS OUR GROUNDWATER
PROBLEMS YOU KNOW WORD NITRIC
PROBLEMS. WE HAVE RUN OFF YOU
KNOW INTO- OR WOULD POTENTIALLY
RUN OFF INTO WATERSHEDS. BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE COST IT'S
A PERK HOW. COST PER DAIRY. SO
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
NORTH BAY HAS DONE AS I STE AS
I MENTIONED WE HAD THE ANIMAL
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
THROUGH SOME KIND OF FORM-
STARTED IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES
WHEN CALVIN PARCHMENT A FISHING
GAME AT THAT TIME COULD NOT
COME UP WITH THE MONEY TO DO
THE TESTING WE IS THURMOND
HIRED. THIRD PARTY- PAST UC
EXTENSION AND- JERRY GUY PASS
WESTERN UNITED FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE THAT HAD. THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE DAIRIES HAD
THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE LAND BUT
ALO WAS VERY REPUTABLE AND WE
PAID HIM TO GO OUT AND DO THE
SAMPLING RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
THREE. THREE GUYS SAID THAT
SAMPLE WE SAMPLED OVER SIXTY
SITES BETWEEN SNOW MARIN COUNTY.
IN THOSE SITES OR YOU KNOW
THOSE REPORTS ARE TURNED INTO
THE WATER BOARD BUT EVERY YEAR
WERE FOUGHT BY ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS THAT THE DAIRIES ARE
POLLUTING OR NOT DOING A GOOD
ENOUGH JOB. AND I THINK THAT'S
THE TOUGHEST THAT'S THE
TOUGHEST ONE IS WHEN. WE'RE
WORKING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO
RUN THE FARM. IT REDUCES WILL
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE AND I SAID IT'S
MANURE MANAGEMENT. BECAUSE ALL
IT TAKES IS ONE LITTLE MISTAKE.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN SOMEBODY'S
GOING BY THE ROAD THEY SAY
APPROVED IN FRONT OF YOUR FARM
AND THEY SEE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE GONNA GET FINE- WE'VE
BEEN VERY PROACTIVE THAT WAY
AND I THINK MOST OF THE FORMS
IN OUR AREA HAVE. I THINK MAYBE
IT TOOK A LITTLE LONGER FOR THE
LARGER DAIRIES IN CENTRAL
VALLEY BUT THEY HAVE COME SO
FAR AND WHAT YOU KNOW WITH THE
HELP OF CARES. HELP WEST UNITED
IN OUR OTHER- JERRY
ORGANIZATIONS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
MOVED. LEAPS AND BOUNDS AHEAD
OF WHERE THE GEHRY ENTRY WAS
YEARS AGO BUT- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU START LOOKING AT WHEN THOSE
FEES COME FROM THE STATE I KNOW
IT'S A PER CAL BUT STILL. IF
YOU DO THE MATH ON. THREE
HUNDRED TO SIX HUNDRED CALS
IT'S COSTING US MORE MONEY.
THAN THE PER CALIFIA AT FIVE
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND CALS.
BECAUSE IT STARTS GETTING SO
HIGH SO THEY FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO CAP IT HERE. BUT
IT ACTUALLY COSTS THE SMALLER
FARMER MORE MONEY FOR THEIR
STATE WATER QUALITY FEE BECAUSE
OF. IF YOU DO THE MATH. YEAH
I'D IN. YEAH I. PRAISE THE
RISK- IN INVENTOR TAKING THAT
JASON HAD MADE AND
DIVERSIFYING- HIS CROPS YOU
TOOK RISKS. IN SOME OF THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING THAT
YOU'RE DOING. HOW DID YOU KIND
OF FACTOR IN HOW MUCH RISK IS
GOING TO BE AND HOW MUCH IS
THIS FOR ME THAT TO BITE OFF-
TO. YOU KNOW TAKE A CHANCE ON
DOING THE RIGHT THING AND DOING
WELL BY IT. I THINK THAT THE
TOUGHEST ONE WAS PROBABLY THE
NUTRIENT OFFSET PROJECT I DID
WITH CITY SANTA ROSA- WE'VE
WE'VE HAD A GREAT PARTNERSHIP.
WITH THE CITY WE'VE UTILIZED
OUR WASTE WATER I KNEW. IF. YOU
KNOW IF THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO-
GET SOME OFFSET CREDITS THAT
THERE THERE WAS NO WAY THEY
COULD TAKE IT- EXPAND THE PLAN
TO PUT THE MONEY BACK IN A PLAN
TO MEET THOSE WATER QUALITY.
REGULATIONS THAT WERE COMING
DOWN ON HIM. SO THEN I POSSIBLY
WOULDN'T HAVE YOUR GEISHA
WATER. BUT AS SOON AS I LET.
THE CONSULTANTS THAT WERE THERE
AND THEY MADE THE PRESENTATION
BEFORE THE REGIONAL WATER BOARD
I GOT TWO PHONE CALLS FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL CAN GROUP SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO SUE YOU COULD
YOU JUST LET THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA SAY THAT YOU WERE. A
POLLUTER MMHM. AND THANK
GOODNESS FOR OUR REGIONAL
BOARD- THEY STEPPED UP AND SAID
NO. WE'RE NOT GONNA EVEN HERE
THIS WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS PROJECT ITS FIRST ONE
EVER DONE THE UNITED STATES. SO
YOU KNOW THOSE ARE KIND OF THE
I HAVE. KIND OF STEPPED OUT ON
SOME OF THESE THINGS BUT IT'S
ALWAYS TO ME THERE THERE'S THAT
BENEFIT I MEAN THAT. THAT
BENEFIT WAS FOR THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA. PLUS IT WAS A
MANAGEMENT BENEFIT. FOR MYSELF.
IN AN AREA THAT I ALWAYS HAD
TROUBLE MANAGING. SAME THING
WITH THE STEP WITH THE OUR
PROGRAM- YEAH IT'S YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE REDUCING ALL THE
METRIC TONS OF CARGO OF YOU
KNOW CO TWO AND EVERYTHING ELSE
BUT IT STILL IS GOING TO
BENEFIT ME ON THE MANAGEMENT
SIDE OF MY FARM. I THERE'S NO
WAY MY PROJECTS SIX HUNDRED
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS THERE'S
NO WAY THAT YOU KNOW IT WOULD
PROBABLY TAKE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
TO REALLY PAY IT BACK AND WHAT
THE SAVINGS I'M GOING TO GET.
FROM A BUSINESS STANDPOINT. BUT
WE ALL DO RECOGNIZED AS YOU
KNOW THE BENEFITS THAT WE'RE
DOING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT YEAH.
I JUST I'VE ALWAYS YOU KNOW THE
PASSIONS THERE YEAH. THE
PASSION TO KEEP THAT LAND WHEN
I. YOU KNOW GO TO BED AND THINK
ABOUT MY GRANDFATHER TELLING
STORIES OF PAIN FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR FOUR
HUNDRED ACRES IN NINETEEN
FIFTY. GOING TO BED TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW HE WAS GOING TO
MAKE THAT PAYMENT. THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN PASSED
DOWN TO THIRD GENERATION. I
DON'T WANT TO SEE IT GO AWAY
YEAH. SO YOU HAVE TO PLAY THE
GAME. BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU YOU KNOW THAT YOU GET
THE BENEFITS ALSO YEAH IT'S
BRING
INTO SHARING SOME OF THIS WAS
DONE- BUT I DO WANT TO ECHO
YOUR PRAISE THAT YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER FOR. OUR OUR CD'S-
WHICH WE'RE TRULY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE IT AS WELL AS YOU SEE
EXTENSION- I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND
THEY BRING A LOT TO OUR
COMMUNITY- SO FOR. FOR
CHRISTINE. ECHOING A LITTLE BIT
ALSO ON ON SENATE DOT HAD
MENTIONED YOU'RE A SECOND
GENERATION FARMER AND EVERY
FARMERS AND ENVIRONMENTALISTS
AND IS DOING DOING THE BEST
THAT THEY CAN- BUT SCIENCE IS
TAKEN SUCH AMAZING LEAPS SINCE
THE LAST GENERATION- I'D LOVE
TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT OF THE-
JUST UNDERSTANDING FAMILY
FARMING WHAT THE CONVERSATION
IS LIKE BETWEEN YOU AND THE
FIRST GENERATION AND HOW YOU
TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE
OTHER GENERATION UNDERSTANDS
WHERE SCIENCE IS GOING OR
PRACTICES ARE GOING BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT'S FACT WHAT'S A
CONVERSATION LIKE AS FAR AS
LIKE WOW WE'RE DOING THIS NOW
AND I YOU KNOW WHATEVER THOSE
BENEFITS MIGHT BE. AND THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME THIS WILL BE
THE LAST RESPONSE FOR THIS
PAST. NO THAT'S OKAY. WELL MY
DAD IS AN IMMIGRANT FROM
SWITZERLAND. SO AND HE CAME
OVER HERE AND STARTED FARMING
IN THE SIXTIES. AND THEN GOT
INTO COMMON FARMING WITH HIS
BROTHER IN THE NIGHT EARLY
NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND SO HE
HAS SEEN A LOT OF CHANGE. I'M
HE'S A YOU KNOW THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY DAD.
THEY'RE VERY OPEN HE IS
ACTUALLY VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE
ALL THE ADVANCES THAT WE HAVE
MADE. EVEN SINCE HE'S RETIRED
ALTHOUGH THEY NEVER REALLY
RETIRE- YOU KNOW ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO AND- HE SOMEBODY
STILL WITH THEIR THERE ARE
RIGHT WITH US ALWAYS INCLUDING.
ALMOST LIKE HISTORICAL
INFORMATION LIKE WELL IT USED
TO BE LIKE THIS BUT NOW YOU
GUYS ARE DOING IT THIS WAY AND
IT'S EVEN BETTER AND I CAN SEE
WHY I MEAN HE DOES VERY THERE
REALLY IS A BIG APPRECIATION
FOR WHERE WE'RE GOING I MEAN IN
THE FACT THAT WE'RE USING SO
MUCH LESS WATER AND WE'RE USING
SO MUCH LESS PESTICIDE. THEN
ALTHOUGH BACK IN THE EARLY
EARLY DAYS WHEN THEY DIDN'T
EVEN HAVE ANY OF THAT STUFF YOU
KNOW HE RECALLS THAT AS WELL HE
ALSO RECOGNIZES THAT SINCE THE
WORLD HAS BECOME WE BECOME SO
MUCH MORE GLOBAL THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING A LOT OF PROBLEMS
THAT ARE NOW COMING IN TO OUR
AREA THAT WERE NEVER THERE WHEN
HE WAS THERE. FOR EXAMPLE
VARONE MY IN THE BEE POPULATION
BECAUSE HE ALSO USED TO KEEP
BEES YOU KNOW THAT'S N
INVASIVE PETE- SPECIES NAVEL
ORANGE WORM WHICH IS A HUGE
PASS THAT WE DEAL WITH ALSO NON
YOU KNOW INVASIVE SPECIES. SO
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE. AND IT'S
ALWAYS HE'S- BEING FROM
SWITZERLAND. AND IT'S SUCH A
HOLE LIKE THEY DO EVERYTHING SO
CLEAN- AND SO THAT'S ALWAYS
BEEN KIND OF AT YOU KNOW. AT
THE TOP. OF HIS GOAL LAST. ANY
I THINK HE'S PROUD THAT WE'RE
GETTING THERE AGAIN LIKE WE'RE
GOING BACK. FANTASTIC IT'S I
REALLY WANT TO THANK OUR PANEL
DOUG HI CHRISTINE- AND JASON
FOR SUCH A- ROBUST- A
DISCUSSION AND- THE
CONVERSATION REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU MAKING THE TIME FOR OUR
HEARING TODAY SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS
AND I'M SURE. YOU KNOW WE HOPE
TO SEE YOU SOON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. IT'S A WIN WE
WANT OUR FINAL PANEL FOR THIS
HEARING- WHICH FEATURES TWO
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING- ONE AN
ACADEMIC AND ONE A WELL KNOWN
ADVOCATE A TO OFFER THEIR IDEAS
AND PROPOSALS FOR HOW WE MIGHT
BEST EXPANSES DATEABLE AND
CLAIM AND CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA I'D
LIKE TO FIRST WELCOME DR
WILLIAM R. HORWATH. CHAIR AND
PROFESSOR OF SOIL BIO GEO
CHEMISTRY IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
LAND AIR AND WATER RESOURCES AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS. WHO WILL BE JOINING US
REMOTELY HIS RESEARCH FOCUSES
ON CROP AND SOIL SCIENCE AND
ECOSYSTEM AND LANDSCAPE ECOLOGY
SO- REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE WITH US DOCTOR AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU. I HAVE SAY THAT LAST
SESSION WAS FANTASTIC- BUT
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION
TO- BE ABLE TO PRESENT MY
RESEARCH I'M GOING TO SHARE THE
SCREEN. ALL I CAN FIND IT-
RIGHT HERE. WELL SEE THAT. YEAH
OKAY. LET'S MAKE AN
INTERPRETATION MONIQUE- CHANGE.
YES S. GOOD FROM THERE
PROFESSOR OKAY. GLASSMAKERS ARE
AGAIN SORRY. IT'S NOT GOING TO
GET IT BACK ALL RIGHT- THE GOAL
IS TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO.
BOTH MAINTAIN AND INCREASE THE
CARBON CONTENT OF SOILS AS A
VERY IMPORTANT OBJECTIVE IT IT.
IT ADDRESSES MANY ENVIRONMENTAL
SERVICES AND IT ALSO. HELPS IN
IN CROP PRODUCTIVITY- IN THAT
IT MAINTAINS STABILITY AND
PROVIDES. MORE EFFICIENT USE OF
RESOURCES. THERE'S A BRIEF
OUTLINE OF GOING ONLY GO
BRIEFLY OVER SOME. OF THE
WORKING LANDS INNOVATION CENTER
I WAS ASKED JUST TO. MENTION
IT- I'D LIKE TO GIVE THE
CONCLUSIONS IN BY. AND WHAT I'M
GOING TO SAY AND I'M GOING TO
SAY THAT. THE ADOPTION MYRICK
MICROIRRIGATION HAS
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED NITROUS
OXIDE EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. IN A REPORT THAT
WE DID FOR CARB- I'M THE
BIOPHYSICAL POTENTIAL TO REDUCE
DOCTORS OXIDE WE DETERMINED OR
OR FROM THE LITERATURE WE
DETERMINED THAT. IF YOU KEEP IT
IN FARMLAND BASICALLY. PRODUCES
UP TO LESS THAN ARE SEVENTY
TIMES LESS THAN ANY OTHER TYPE
OF BLANK USE LIKE URBAN OR
DEVELOPED. WELL WE HAVE SOME
DECADE ALONG RESEARCH THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON SINCE THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES AT UC DAVIS
TO ADDRESS THAT POTENTIAL TO
SEQUESTER CARBON. WE LOOK
MOSTLY AT COVER CROPS COMPOST
IN THE WAR AND CROP ROTATIONS.
ONE CARRY OUT A BOX QUESTION
CARBON IS THAT YOU NEED TO ADD
MORE NITROGEN. AND THAT I WANT
TO HELP WITH THE POLICY SLIDE
RULE. BALL SO THE WORKING LANDS
INNOVATION CENTER WAS- THE
PROJECT BEEN FUNDED BY THE
STATE WELL IT'S LOOKING AT
OTHER TYPES OF WAYS TO INCREASE
ALL CARBON SEQUESTRATION
PARTICULARLY CRUSHED. AND
BAYRAKTAR ALSO LOOKING A
COMPOST- COMPOST IS NOW. SIR WE
HOPE TO DO THAT ARE DIVERT FOOD
WASTE FOR EXAMPLE THROUGH
COMPOSTING FACILITIES TO
INCREASE BOTH THE AMOUNT AND
QUALITY OF THE COMPOST. SOME
PRELIMINARY RESULTS FROM THE
PROJECT SHOWS THAT THERE ARE
INCREASED BICARBONATE LEVELS IN
SOILS THAT HAVE BEEN THAT
CRUSHED ROCK HAS BEEN APPLIED
TO. WE'LL HAVE TO CONTINUE THAT
RESEARCH IT TAKES YEARS THREE
TO FIVE YEARS OR MORE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THIS
IS ALL SIGNIFICANT. INCREASES
OUR CARBON. SO JUST TO TAKE
HOME THE POINT THESE PROJECTS
WERE ALL DONE ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO WHEN BE IMPLEMENTED SB
THIRTY TWO- LOOKING AT WAYS TO
REDUCE TAXES OXIDE EMISSIONS-
FROM AGRICULTURE IT TURNS OUT
THAT. IT'S ADOPTING NEW
TECHNOLOGIES PARTICULARLY MICRO
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS. HAVE
RESULTED IN A DRAMATIC
REDUCTION OF. NITROUS OXIDE
EMISSIONS WHICH IN ITSELF
REQUIREMENT FOR BETTER THEN- IT
FROM A COUPLE OF CLIMATE
WARMING POTENTIAL AND QUESTION
FOR CARBON IT'S- BECAUSE IT CAN
BE DONE EVERY YEAR HE COULD BE
DEBT CONSISTENTLY. AND YASSER
TO COURT- SO JUST HERE QUICKLY
MOVES. IN MOST OF OUR STUDIES
EXACTLY IN EVERY EXAMPLE EAT
HEALTH WEALTH WELL IN GRAPES.
ALMONDS AND WALNUTS IF YOU HAVE
A MICROIRRIGATION SYSTEMS LIKE
A SUBSURFACE DRIP SYSTEM THAT
CAN BE SURPLUS. OUGHT IT
GENERALLY PRODUCES LESS MATCHES
OXIDE AND WHERE YOU CAN ADD
KNOW THAT CHEAPER LIGHTER UNDER
FLOOD IRRIGATION SYSTEM. SO WE
ARE QUITE ENTHUSED ABOUT THIS
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING TO SORT OF
GET THIS OUT AND EVERY TIME I
THINK IT'S COOL BUT NEVER SEEMS
TO REALLY RESONATE AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE IT RESONATE HERE.
THAT THE INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
LOOKING. FOR SO. EVERYONE KNOWS
THE FORMER NUMBER OBJECTIVES IT.
INQUIRES ABOUT QUITE SIX TONS
OF CARBON THREE YEAR ALLEN
AVERAGED ACROSS ALL GLOBAL
LANDS OUR OUR GLOBAL
AGRICULTURAL LAND. ATTENTIONAL
FROM RESEARCH STUDIES SUGGEST
AN AGRICULTURE CROPLAND IT'S
ABOUT WHAT WHAT THE ONE POINT
TWO COUNTS OF CARPER. TONS OF
CARBON PER HECTARE PRETTY.
GRAZING LANDS IN THE SAME ORDER
OF MAGNITUDE- DISTURBS SOIL AS
WELL WHAT I WOULD CALL OUT
PEATLAND RESTORATION AND- DELTA
WHICH HAS A MUCH HIGHER
POTENTIAL I THINK MORE EFFORT
SHOULD BE PUT INTO THE DELTA IN
RECOVERING WELL SOILS AND
MINIMIZING THE EFFECT OF LUCK
INSTABILITY FOR EXAMPLE. AND
THE WATER SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
PER SE. SO IN CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE ABOUT THE POTENTIAL USING
COVER CROPS COMPOSTED MANURE-
AND CROP ROTATIONS. YOU GET
ABOUT QUITE ONE TWO POINT THREE
TONS OF CARBON ACTIVE. AND I'LL
GO OVER THIS OUR STUDIES THAT
WE'VE DERIVED FROM NATION FROM.
THE STUDY HERE WAS STARTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND TWO
THOUSAND TWO WAS POLICY LIKE
FARMING SYSTEM PROJECT IT
LOOKED AT CONVENTIONAL FARMING.
I FARMING THAT INCORPORATED
WINTER COVER CROP AND ORGANIC
FARMING ORGANIC FARMING IS WITH
EIGHT COVER CROP AND MANURE
ADDITION- SO YOU SEE THAT THE
ORGANIC SYSTEM. IT'S ABOUT WHAT
MAX OR WHAT WE CAN SEE OUT AS
THESE STUDIES THIS IS POINT
THREE TIMES PER HECTARE PER
YEAR SO FOUR TO FIVE TIMES
MAYBE IN TEN YEARS WHICH IS NOT
IS VERY SIGNIFICANT. IF YOU
JUST DO A COVER CROP ALONG. GET
ABOUT TWO POINT TWO TONNES PER
HECTARE. IN OUR CENTURY
EXPERIMENT AT RUSSELL RANCH ALL
VERY SIMILAR EXPERIMENTAL
DESIGN SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT. I'LL
BE CONVENTIONAL IN THIS CASE
AGAIN POPPING OUT WITH STANDARD
TELL. STANGEL THE COVER CROP
HERE WE HAVE LAST BUT IT WAS
THE COVER CROP. IT HASN'T BEEN
PLANET IS EVERY YEAR- THROUGH
THE DURATION OF THE PROJECT
EVERY OTHER YEAR. SO THAT'S THE
ISSUE- WITH USING COVER CROPS
IT HAS TO BE DONE EVERY YEAR TO
GET THAT POTENTIAL ALL. AND IF
YOU DO IT EVERY OTHER YEAR ARE
VERY INCONSISTENTLY OR EVEN
COMPOST ADDITIONS
INCONSISTENTLY YEAH THAT. THE
QUESTION DETENTION PRIEST.
EITHER FOR ARMENIAN SIMILAR TO
THE OTHER PROJECTS THAT POINT
THREE. ANOTHER PROJECT W
STARTED NINETEEN NINETY NINE AT
THE UC WEST SIDE OUR RESEARCH
AND EDUCATION CENTER IS WE LOOK
AT THE FACT IT UNTIL. WE ARE
INITIALLY VERY ENTHUSED ABOUT
NO DEAL BECAUSE IT SEEMED TO BE
SEQUESTERING CARBON. LIKE EACH
WILL BALANCE BUT NOW AFTER
TWENTY YEARS. YOU HAVE TO SORT
OF TEMPER OUR ASSESSMENT. AND
IT SHOWS THAT NO DEAL IS
ESSENTIALLY MATCH. US THE
QUESTION CARBON AT THE RATE WE
THOUGHT. THAT MAKES KIND OF
SENSE IN AN ARID DRY
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE IN-
TURNS OUT THAT CHALLENGE-
ACTUALLY DID BETTER THAN NO
JAIL WITH NO COVER NOPE NOPE
STANDARD DELAGE COVER CROP
RESEARCH NOTE YELLOW COVER PROP
YOU ACTUALLY LOST SOME CARBON
INTELLECTUAL SYSTEM. SO MIXING
THAT RESIDUE IN THE SOIL IS
IMPORTANT TO GET IT TO THE
MICROBIAL MOUTH TO CONVERT IT
TO SOIL ORGANIC MATTER- THE
STANDARD TILL COVER CROP I
TURNED OUT TO. GET SIMILAR
SEQUESTRATION RIGHTS DANDY
ORGANIC SYSTEM. OVER TIME. ADAM
I THINK HE'S RATES ARE ALSO
PROMISED BY THE FACT THAT THE
DE SOROS IN THE SOUTHERN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY HAVE LOWER
CARBON CONTENT AND THEY HAVE A
GREATER POTENTIAL. TO SEQUESTER
CARBON AT A FASTER RATE. AND
SHE- ONE THING I HAVEN'T. RIVAS
LINES WELL- YEAH IN THE ORGANIC
SYSTEM IN THE RUSSELL RANCH
RECENT DEEP CARBON. THAT
AMOUNTS TO ALMOST TWICE AS MUCH
AS THIS CARD- BUT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO QUANTIFY YOUNGER
OUR QUALIFICATION TICKETS AT
THE EXPENSE WOULD BE. BUT WE
SEE THAT IN STANDARD TELL IN IN
IN THE- WEST SIDE- YOU'LL
STATION. WHERE WE DO SEE DEEPER
CARBON AS WELL SO IF YOU GO
BLIND BEYOND THE STANDARD SOIL
SAMPLING DEPTH WE MAY BE ABLE
TO FIND THE BUSINESS CARD BUT
THERE'S A THERE'S A HUGE
EXPENSE FOR DOING THAT- IN A
LOT OF VERY ABILITY SO IF.
THERE IS A LOT OF PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH. ALL SO I'M
GONNA. BUT ONE THAT WE GET SO
SCIENTISTS TEND NOT ALWAYS
KNOWLEDGE THAT IF YOU SEQUESTER
CARBON IN SOIL YOU HAVE TO
SEQUESTER NITROGEN WITH IT. SO
FOR EVERY EIGHT TO TEN. OR
EXCUSE ME EIGHT TO TWELVE ATOMS
OF CARBON YOU'LL NEED ONE ATOM
OF NITROGEN. THAT'S WHAT THE
CHEMISTRY OF SOLAR IF MATTER IS
THAT'S THE STILL KIANA. SO THE
QUESTION CARBON ALSO REQUIRE
SEQUESTERING NITROGEN. AND IF
WE DON'T SEQUESTER IF WE FOLLOW
THE FOUR PER THOUSAND PROTOCOL
OUR INITIATIVE I'LL WE WOULD
NEED TO- TO SOMEHOW EITHER TO
COVER CROPPING OR OR RECYCLING
AND THAT WE BOTTOM NORMALLY
WASTED HUNDRED EXTRA CARE
GRANTS PER YEAR OR- AN AMOUNTS
TO ABOUT FIFTY KILOGRAMS PER
HECTARE OR PROXIMITY FIFTY
POUNDS. PER ACRE PER YEAR YOU
HAVE TO REALIZE THAT WHEN WE%
PUT THESE AMENDMENTS DOWN WE
PUT A COVER CROP IN OR WE PUT
COUPLES TELL ME THEY WERE DOWN
WE OFTEN. OR WE HAVE TO BY
STATE LAW ABOUT IT KNOWLEDGE
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THE PLANT.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE USED
AND NOT USED TO SEQUESTER
CARBON SO THERE MAY HAVE TO BE
ADDITIONAL. NITROGEN ADDED AND
THAT'S NOT. AND IT'S A SCARY
THING STAY. I BECAUSE WE TO
HAVE- INCREASED ENERGY
EFFICIENCY JUMPER OUR-
RESOURCES AFTER WATER RESOURCE-
DISPUTE WRAP UP- ONE THING I
DID MENTION IS THAT ONCE
CALIFORNIA. DEVELOP ALL THE
WATER PROJECTS AND START YOUR
GETTING PLANNED SO COVERED
ACTUALLY INCREASED OVER TIME IN
MANY PLACES PARTICULARLY IN
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
BECAUSE THE PRODUCTIVITY OF
AGRICULTURAL SYSTEMS WAS
GREATER THAN THE NATIVE.
ECOSYSTEMS SO IN SOME PLACES
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN INCREASING
SOIL CARBON REGARDLESS OF THE
INTENSIFICATION HAS OCCURRED
IN- IN AGRICULTURE- CALIFORNIA.
MY ADDITION HAS DRAMATICALLY
MATCHES OXIDE EMISSIONS. NO
TELL MAIN INCREASE TOTALS ALL
CARBON. IN ALL CASES SOCOM'S
RESTRICTION REQUIRES AN- WE
SHOULD PRIOR TO RESOURCE PRIDE
PRIORITIZE OUR SOILS- UP WHERE
WE PUT OUR COMPOST IN THE NEW
ONES AND I THINK AG LAND AT THE
MOST AND AGAIN SHE BEGIN
FARMLAND IS. ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS TO KEEP UP CLIMATE
FRIENDLY ALL. TYPE OF SCENARIO.
URBAN WITH ABLE. SO CAN WE DO
IT I JUST KIND OF SHOW YOU WE
CAN QUESTOR CARBON IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT HAS AN ELEGANT
PAPER BY AND ITS IN PROFESSOR
OF SOIL SCIENCE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. I SUBMITTED THIS AS
FOR YOU TO- AS MATERIALS IT'S
EASY IT'S EASY WORKING READING
BUT IT'S VERY VERY. VERY
ELEGANT. RESENTS THE PROBLEMS
OF. THE QUEST FOR MARKET AND
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS THE
NATURALLY'S TECHNICIAN SIR. AB.
MOST OF MY NAME A QUESTION A
TON. THIS. EIGHTY THREE. WAY
ABOVE THE MARK. SO THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE PUBLIC AND SOME AND
THAT'S BECAUSE THE LARGEST
TRADE COSTS. THANK COME ACROSS
OR- DOING SO CURRENT REQUIRE
ALL INCOME LABOR ALL HER
PROPERTIES ACTUALLY IN SHORTS.
I'M NOT ALWAYS SUITABLE RIGHT
SEE AVAILABLE FOR EVERY APPLE.
VERCELLI OF THE QUESTION IS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE. BOB THE
LAST ASSISTANCE CHECK
ASSISTANCE PARTICULARLY FROM
USED COOPER EXTENSION AND
THAT'S TRUST SERVICE TO YOU
FARMERS AND GIVING IT THANK
INFORMATION. AND TRYING TO HELP
DO. YOU SEE NEXT HAS BEEN IN
SOME SECURE EVER SINCE I CAME
HERE IN NINETEEN SIX. AND
COURSE THESE FARMERS ARE DURING.
SO I WOULD THAT WE DO THE SAME
AS WE GET WITH WATER. FILE AND-
BIOPHYSICAL FACTORS WARMING
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK AGAINST
US IF WE GET SIGNIFICANT
WARMING IN CALIFORNIA THAT WILL
SLOW DOWN. SPEECH AND THAT AND
JUST SO QUESTION CARBON MAY
IMPACT FUTURE CROP GROWTH IS
TOO MUCH CARBON COULD BE BACK
TO WE NEED PROBABLY RESEARCH
INTO THAT SO WE KNOW THAT
INCREASING SOIL CARBON AT A
REASONABLE RATE. INCREASES PROP
CROP PRODUCTIVITY INSTABILITY
BUT IF WE- FOUR SIX WE MAY HAVE
OTHER ISSUES THEN WE SEEN THAT
HAPPEN IN FOR SYSTEMS THAT WERE
RELEASED LAST BEHIND ENEMY GETS
SLOWER GROWTH OF THE- NEXT
FORCED. OKAY KEEPING AG LAND
WILL BE SEVENTY BY UP 270%
TIMES LESS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAN OTHER TYPES OF
LAND USE BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
HERE I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH
IS THAT SO CARBON IMPROVE SO
MANY THINGS WATER RETENTION
WATER INFILTRATION YIELD
STABILITY IN CROPS FOOD
SECURITY ECOSYSTEM SERVICES SO
ANY AMOUNT LOOKS THE CARBON CAN
BE SEQUESTERED WE'LL ALL BE OUT
AHEAD OF THE GAME AND IN DEEP
WATERS. THANK YOU. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
IT'S- YESTERDAY THE INFORMATION
I'M SURE WE'LL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- AT THE END OF THE
PANEL- AND BEFORE YOU KNOW IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO. WELCOME CAT
TAYLOR WHO'S ALSO JOINING US
REMOTELY- MISS TAYLOR ADVOCATES
PASSIONATELY. AND EFFECTIVELY
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SMART POLICIES
ALONG WITH HER HUSBAND TOM
STIERS. SHE FOUNDED THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED ACRES TOM CAT
RANCH IN THE BAY AREA. AN
OPERATION EXPLORES AND PROMOTES
REGENERATIVE AND SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICES. WELCOME
IS TAYLOR IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU
AGAIN- WE'RE DELIGHTED TO HAVE
YOU ROUND OUT THIS PANEL AND
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS AND THE COMMITTEE- THANK
YOU FOR FASTER FOR YOUR LAST
POINT ESPECIALLY. THAT WAS
REALLY INTERESTING SO- I'M- MY
NAME'S CAT TAYLOR AND I'M GONNA
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY
WE ARE INVOLVED IN THE HEARING
TODAY- TOMCAT RANCH IS A
LEARNING LABORATORY ANALYZING
DE RISKING AND BROADCASTING
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE FOR
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS- I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES GOING TO SHARE. A
SCREEN TO PRESENT A DECK OR
MAYBE THE- MANY S. JUST JUST
ONE MOMENT I A- THERE IS A
TECHNICAL ISSUE WHERE I HAVE TO
RESTART IT AND GIVE IT THAT
PERMISSION I APOLOGIZE IT
SHOULD BE ONE MINUTE. NO
WORRIES I'LL KEEP GOING- WE'LL
BE FINE. SO FOR THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
COALESCING WITH HUNDREDS OF
BRANCHES IN CALIFORNIA ACROSS
TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES COVERING
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES IN
MONITORING FOR THE PROMISE OF
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE AND
RANCHING. WE HAVE ONSITE
SCIENCE PARTNERS IN POINT BLUE
CONSERVATION SCIENCE OF WILL BE
IN ON PROPERTY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND THEY A AND WE
HAVE DATA TO BACK UP ALL THE
ASSERTIONS THAT WE WILL MAKE
TODAY. IN COLLABORATION WITH
WHITE BLUE WE HAVE HELPED
INSPIRE OVER TWO MILLION ACRES
OF RANGELAND IN CALIFORNIA TO
SHIP TO REGENERATIVE PRACTICE
WE ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO LANDRY
MATURATION OF RETURNING LAD TO
INDIGENOUS AND BLACK FOOD WAYS.
AND PEOPLE WE ARE EXPLORING
COOPERATIVE OWNERSHIP MODELS OF
FARMWORKERS FARMER PLANS- AND
LAND TRUSTS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE GIVES
US SIX FIVE FOLD OPPORTUNITY TO
BENEFIT CALIFORNIANS ALONG THE
LINES SUGGESTED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
THIRTY BY THIRTY. AND
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS AS WELL AS OUR
COMMITMENT TO RACIAL EQUITY
GENDER EQUITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE- BEES- PROMISES AND
OPPORTUNITIES ARE REFLECTED IN
THE CALIFORNIA AGENCIES
ADVISORIES OF NATURAL RESOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
INCLUDING AGRICULTURE AS WELL
AS THE BUYING CLIMATE PLAN. AND
WE STAND READY TO HELP CREATE
THE CONDITIONS FOR YOUR SUCCESS
TWO. OF YOU WILL HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED A PAMPHLET THAT IS THE
PRESENTATION IN MUCH GREATER
DETAIL AND THAT WE ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SHARE WITH STAFF AND USE
AS A REFERENCE. A NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO THIS IS THE
CHECKLIST OF THE DEMANDS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
RETURN 30% OF CALIFORNIA'S
LANDS IN RANIERI'S TO
CONSERVATION INCLUDING WORKING
LANDS WE HAVE HAD TAKEN MANY
INSIGHTS IN OUR WORK OVER THE
YEARS AND- ESPECIALLY MOST
RECENTLY AND GROWING THE TABLE.
A PROGRAM IN COLLABORATION WITH
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS TO
AVOID FOOD WASTE AND FEED
HUNGRY CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
TIME. AND WE WOULD ASSERT THAT
ARE- CURRENT INDUSTRIAL
CONCENTRATED VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED ACTS SYSTEM IS
SUFFERING. FROM BRITTLENESS
SOME INJUSTICE IN ON
SUSTAINABILITY IN WAYS THAT WE
CAN REDUCE ADDRESSED THROUGH
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE- END.
JUST TO NOTE FARMS FARMERS AND
RANCHERS ARE THE HEROES OF THIS
STORY- OUR ESTEEMED SCIENTISTS
HAVE PREDICTED THAT WE HAVE
NONE THE LESS ONLY SIXTY MORE
HARDEST LEFT UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. SO WE DO NEED A NEW
PARADIGM WHERE AND TO US IT IS
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE- ED
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE IN
MANY WAYS IS A RETURN TO LONG
STANDING TRADITIONS OF FOOD AND
FARMING. AND IT DOES- UGH
PROVIDE FOR US MANY OF THE
QUALITIES THAT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER MANDATES LIKE RACIAL
EQUITY ECOLOGICAL REPAIR AND
ECONOMIC VIABILITY. AND WE HAVE
READY TO IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS
WITHIN REGENERATIVE
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE FOR
THE AGENCIES THE LEGISLATURE
AND THIS COMMITTEE. OF 30% OF
OUR LANDS ARE ALREADY POISED
FOR A VOLUNTARY NATURAL
RESOURCE CONSERVATION SERVICE
CLIMATE BENEFICIAL PRACTICES
THAT'LL ENSURE BIODIVERSITY
FOOD SECURITY AND ECONOMIC
RESILIENCY- AND THE WATER
BENEFITS THAT COME ARE A
TENDON- IN PRE SEEDS SOIL AND
CARBON CO BENEFITS. HAD THEIR
OWN VALUE FOR CALIFORNIA AS
WELL NOT TO MENTION THIS WILL
BE A GIANT JOBS PROGRAM. UP FOR
UPGRADED WE'RE IN THE ACCESS IT
WILL US THIS TO PRISON. THAT IS
DEVASTATING THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
ESSENTIALLY THE EXECUTIVE ORDER
IS IT TEED UP BASEBALL FOR
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE HIT A
HOME RUN. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE. SO
WHAT IS REGENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE WE HAVE TO FIND IT
WITH POINT BLUES SCIENCE AS THE
SCIENCE ART OR OCCUPATION THAT
PROVIDES AMPLE NUTRITIOUS FOOD
IMPROVE LOCAL ECONOMIES
SUPPORTS RACIAL AND GENDER
EQUITY BILLS SOIL FERTILITY
RESTORES BIODIVERSITY ABOVE AND
BELOW THE GROUND. OPTIMIZES
WATER CYCLING AND QUALITY AND
ALL BY USING NATURAL PROCESS
SEES WITH MINIMAL OFF FARM
INPUTS THAT SHE CLIMATE
STABILITY BY RESEARCH BY SPRINT
CARBON ANOTHER ESSENTIAL
NUTRIENTS TO THE SOIL WHERE
CARBON CAN DO NO HARM- NOTE
THAT I NEED TO TALK TO
PROFESSOR I HOPE YOU CAN LEARN
MORE ABOUT THAT. OF THE SIX
CORE PRINCIPLES OF REGENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE ARE TO CONSIDER THE
CONTEXT BECAUSE WE HAVE GREAT
DIVERSITY IS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO MINIMIZE SOIL
DISTURBANCE MAXIMIZE DIVERSITY
IN THE CROP SOIL AND
ECOSYSTEMS. KEEP THE SOIL
COVRED WITH COVER CROPS
MAINTAIN YEAR ROUND LONG ROOTED
PLANTS AND REAR INTEGRATE
LIVESTOCK WE SHOULD ALSO
INCLUDE THE ATTENDANT OF
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE IS TO
MINIMIZE OR AVOID OFF FARM
INPUTS ESPECIALLY EXPENSIVE
CHEMICALS. THIS DEFINITION OF
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE HAS
BEEN ACCEPTED BY LARGE CONSUMER
PRODUCT COMPANIES LIKE GENERAL
MILLS NESTLE AS WELL AS MY
MISSION DRIVEN SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE PRICES LIKE
PATAGONIA AND ANNIE'S ORGANICS-
IT SHOULD WE SHOULD NOTE THAT
THESE PRINCIPLES COMPOUND WHEN
APPLIED TOGETHER FOR MAXIMO THE
SECT AND MULTIPLE CO BENEFITS-
AS WELL AS- HELP OF. WAS MEET
OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND COMBAT
SHOCKS LIKE FLOOD DROUGHT. AND
PESTILENCE NEXT SLIDE. SO THE
IS A DAY OF HOUSE RESTRUCTURING
XIN OF CARBON WORKS IN WHAT
LATE TERMS AND THAT'S WHAT I AM
A LAYPERSON ESSENTIALLY THE
PROCESS OF PHOTOSYNTHESIS THE
PLAN. IS YOU'RE CONVERTING
SOLAR ENERGY- TO CARBOHYDRATES
AND SUGARS WHICH IT EXPECTS
CHANGES WITH THE RICH MICROBIAL
COMMUNITY BELOW GROUND FOUR OF
FIVE ORGANISMS IN THE WORLD
LIVE IN OUR SOIS. AND THEY RUN
ALONG ARE MYCORRHIZAL HIGHWAYS
MINING AND ESSENTIAL MINERALS
AND NUTRIENTS WHICH THE-
MICROSOMAL COMMUNITY THEN
EXCHANGES WITH THAT PLANT IN-
FOR THOSE CARBOHYDRATES AND
SUGAR WHICH CONSTITUTES SOIL.
SOIL CARBON IN THE GROUND-
THERE IS- ADDED BENEFIT TO DEEP
SOIL CARBON IN THE SENSE THAT
IT REMAINS MORE DURABLY AND IS
NOT RESPONDING OR TO
PHOTOSYNTHESIS- PROCESS SEES
AFTER THE FACT- THE INTEGRATION
OF LIVESTOCK IS IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THOSE ANIMALS ARE
QUICKLY- CLIPPING OFF JUST THE
A SHORT BIT OF THE PLANT WHICH
INSPIRES A PLANT TO GROW AGAIN
BECAUSE A PLAN IS ALWAYS
SEEKING TO BALANCE ITS BIOMASS
ABOVE THE GROUND WITH THIS
BIOMASS BELOW THE GROUND. THE
END WE DO BELIEVE THERE IS
SIMPLE SOIL TESTING COMING THAT
WILL HELP US BENCHMARK SOIL
CARBON IN A WAY THAT WILL OPEN
UP THE SOIL CARBON MARKETS
WHICH WILL TALK ABOUT. LATER
NEXT SITE. THE DIFFERENCE IS
CLEAR TO THE HI AND I KNOW WE
DO NEED TO MEASURE
SCIENTIFICALLY BUT YOU CAN SEE
IN THIS PICTURE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A DEPLETED SOIL AND A
HEALTHY SOIL EXIDE. SO A
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE
PROVIDES PLENTIFUL AND
VERIFIABLE CO BENEFITS IT'S A
PERFECTLY SYNCHRONIZED TOOL TO
GARNER ROBUST WORLD ECONOMIES
BIODIVERSITY OF ABOVE AND BELOW
THE GROUND AND IN THE
FARMHOUSE. HI WATER QUALITY IN
QUANTITY FOOD SYSTEM RESILIENCY
RACIAL AND SOCIAL JUSTICE SO
HEALTH AND FERTILITY CLIMATE WE
SAMPLE AS ASIAN HUMAN OUT
WELLNESS INCLUDING FOR
FARMWORKERS AND ANIMAL WELFARE
LET'S GO THROUGH ONE BY ONE. SO
ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF RATE
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. IS INCREASED
WATER INFILTRATION TO PROVIDE
WILL HAVE A HIGHER QUANTITY AND
QUALITY OF WATER IN OUR SOILS
THE GROUND COVERED BY HEALTHY
PLANTS INFILTRATES WATER AND RE
HYDRATES SOILS. BARE GROUND BY
CONTRAST CAUSES RUNOFF EROSION
AND FLOODING REHYDRATED SOILS
AREN'T EXCELLENT WAY TO COMBAT
FIRES FLOODS AND DROUGHT WHICH
ARE CHRONIC CONDITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WATER
INFILTRATION TRACKS CARBON THE
SEQUESTRATION IN A READILY
VERIFIED WEIGHT ALREADY AMPLE
WATER AND THE RESULT IN HIGHER
YIELDS ALLOWS FARMERS TO RESIST
DEVELOPMENT THAT VERY EXPENSIVE
CONVERSION THAT THE PROFESSOR
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT. AND
WATER IS A HUGE ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. SLIDE NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. WE ALSO CAN MAKE
THE BUSINESS CASE FOR
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE AS IT
GENERATES GREATER AND MORE
RELIABLE PROFITS FOR FARMERS
AND RANCHERS HERE'S WHERE THAT
HAPPENS ALL THESE ARE ALL THE
INCREASE SOURCES OF REVENUE
ASSOCIATED WITH REGENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE AND THE RESULTING
DECREASED COSTS A FAMOUS
EXAMPLE IS GAY BROWN WHO'S BEEN
FARMING AN IDENTICAL FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES IN NORTH DAKOTA
DO YOU HIS COMMODITY GROWING
NEIGHBORS AND WHERE HE IS
ACHIEVING TWELVE TIMES OR
REVENUE THAT HIS NEIGHBORS KO.
BUT PLEASE ALSO SEE IN THE MORE
DETAIL PAMPHLET OUR BUSINESS
PROFILES VERY HIGHLY EVIDENCED
WITH REAL GROWERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. NEXT SLIDE.
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURAL ALSO
RESTORES AND PROTECTS
BIODIVERSITY ON WORKING LANDS
WHICH IS A HALLMARK OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. A TOMCAT RICH
ALONE HOST OVER A HUNDRED
MIGRATORY BIRDS WHO ARE LEADING
INDICATORS OF ECOLOGICAL HEALTH
ARE PLANNED GRAZING BOTH
PROTECTS AND RESTRICTS THE
PRESENCE OF CATTLE SO THAT
ABUNDANT LARGE FAUNA HAVE
PLENTY OF PREY. TO HUNT AWAY
FROM THE- CATTLE HERD- I'M
RESTORING IN OUR CASE KEYSTONE
ANIMALS LIKE MOUNTAIN LIOS
BADGER FOX DEER AND COYOTES ALL
OF WHICH SUGGEST A VERY HEALTHY
HEALTHY ECOSYSTEM BELOW THEM.
NEXT SLIDE- WORKING LANDS ARE A
KEY CLIMATE SOLUTION AT SCALE-
THIS IS A CHART SHOWING THAT IF
NATIONALLY ALL THE CRAP WENT
ALL AGRICULTURAL LANDS ADOPTED
JUST FOUR OF THE TWENTY NINE
ENTERS YES PRACTICES THAT WOULD
BE- IS THAT. EASIER ONES TO
ADMINISTER- WE WOULD REACH ZERO
EMISSIONS IN AGRICULTURE BY
TWENTY FORTY- NEXT SLIDE. AND
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE
CREATES- THESE VICTORIES AT
SCALE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL A HUNDRED
MILLION ACRES IN CALIFORNIA
JUST A 1% INCREASE IN THE SOIL
ORGANIC MATTER ON THE TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION OF THEM DECADES
CROPLANDS WINS WHAT WOULD
SEQUESTER THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR MILLION MEGATONS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE. WHICH IS NEARLY TWELVE
TIMES THE CURRENT GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION SHORTFALL THAT
WE'RE FACING IT'S EQUIVALENT TO
AVOIDING EMISSIONS FROM SEVENTY
TWO MILLION VEHICLE MILES EACH
YEAR AND INCREASES OUR ANNUAL
WATER BY ONE AND A HALF MILLION
ACRE FEET OR FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT TRILLION GALLONS
EACH YEAR. AT JUST A SIDE NOTE
OF BECAUSE I LOVE THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE ABOUT
ALMONDS COVER CROPPING A LOAN
ON THE ONE POINT THREE MILLION
ACRES OF ALMONDS IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD SEQUESTER TWO MILLION
MEGATONS OF CARBON DIOXIDE EACH
YEAR. NEXT SLIDE. AND THERE'S A
COMPOUNDING EFFECT- TO
REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE THAT
WILL HELP US REACH A NEW
EQUILIBRIUM THIS SYMBIOTIC
CONNECTION BETWEEN WATER CARBON
IN PLANTS BENEFITS US ALL.
WATER AGAIN IS A PROXY FOR
CARBON WHEN WE GET WATER RIGHT
USUALLY GET SOIL AND CARBON
RIGHT AS WELL. THE INCREASE
PHOTOSYNTHESIS CREATES MORE
SOIL ORGANIC MATTER THAT ALLOWS
MORE WATER HOLDING CAPACITY AND
IN TURN INCREASES
PHOTOSYNTHESIS IN THE PROCESS
THIS CONTINUOUS CYCLE INCREASES
BIODIVERSITY SAFEGUARDS
ECONOMIC SUSTAINABILITY AND
FOOD SECURITY. AND WILL HELP US
MEET OUR TWENTY FORTY FIVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL NEXT
SLIDE. IN SHORT REGENERATIVE
AGRICULTURE IS A FIVE FOLD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT WILL REDUCE
EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
AGRICULTURE THAT ARE ESTIMATED
TO BE BETWEEN TWENTY TWO AND
42% OF ALL WORLD GREENHOUSE
GASES. IT WILL RECENT WESTER
CARBON KIT BECAUSE WE WON'T GET
TO OUR CLIMATE GOALS BY
EMISSION REDUCTION ALONE. IT
PROVIDES REAL TOOLS TO MITIGATE
WILDFIRE FLOOD DROUGHT AND
PESTILENCE THEY'RE HERE TO
STAY- IT EMPOWERS FOR A RACIAL
AND GENDER EQUITY AND I'D WITH
MORE DEMAND FOR A BLACK
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE OF COLOR
GROWERS. AND IT CAN GALVANIZE
ABROAD A STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO
DELIVER A STRONG POLITICAL BASE
FOR CHANGE. ALL WEBER SPROUT
ALL WHILE RESTORING OUR
DEPLETED SOILS. NEXT. FIVE AND
WE ARE READY TO PROPOSE TO YOU
READY TO IMPLEMENT BIG IDEAS-
TO ACHIEVE THE WIN WIN WIN WIN
WIN FOR CALIFORNIA GROWERS. THE
BIG IDEA NUMBER ONE IS TO
CREATE A STATEWIDE MONITORING
EFFORT- THAT IS ALREADY UNDER
WAY BE THAT THROUGH POINT LOSE
RANGE THAT MONITORING NETWORK
OR THE TOTAL AG MONITORING OF
IS RE AND THE JET PROPULSION
LAB COAT- COLLABORATION
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY LEADING
THE WAY BUT THERE ARE ALSO
EFFORTS TO CREATE A NATIONAL
SOIL CARBON REGISTRY THAT WOULD
ENABLE SOIL CARBON MARKET. AND
ECHOES OF THE SAME IN THE
BUYING CLIMATE PLAN. THE BIG
GUY NUMBER TWO IS TO SCALE
RECOGNIZED USDA NRCS PRACTICES
WITH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
INCENTIVES EXISTING PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INCENTIVES ALREADY
INCLUDE THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM DISCUSSING DAY. ZERO
CALIFORNIA FOOD FOR CALIFORNIA
KIDS GUIDING SCHOOL DISTRICT
PURCHASING. GROWING THE TABLE
AVOIDING FOOD WASTE AND FEEDING
THE HUNGRY NEW CROP INSURANCE
PRODUCTS. PRODUCTS THAT
GUARANTEE EXPECTED YIELDS WHEN
CARBON FARMING PRACTICES ARE
APPLIED- AND SOIL IN CARBON
ECOSYSTEM SERVICES MARKETS. THE
GUY NUMBER IDEA NUMBER THREE
WHICH HAS BEEN SUGGESTED BY
OTHERS TO DATE TO PROVIDE
ENHANCED AND CONSISTENT ACCESS
TO PROFESSIONAL TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. NRCS RCD EXTENSION
AND SHE GOES STATE'S
REGENERATIVE INSTITUTE ARE
ALREADY PROVIDING INFIELD
CONSULTING- AND CARBON FARM
PLANNING SERVICES AND COULD BE
FUNDED TO GREATER EFFECT. THIS
WIN WIN WIN WIN WIN SOLUTION
CENTER REGENERATIVE AGRICULTURE
CAN GALVANIZE A BROAD AND
DIVERSE COALITION OF
STAKEHOLDERS FROM CLIMATE TO
CONSERVATION FROM FOOD TO
HEALTHCARE FROM LABOR TO AG
FROM EDUCATION TO RACIAL AND
GENDER EQUITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TIME TODAY AND
PLEASE DO YOU DISTRIBUTE THE
PAMPHLETS TO YOUR STAFF AND
OTHER CONCERNED STAKEHOLDERS.
MISS TAYLOR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION ON
GREAT INFORMATION- WE HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIVING.
YEAH HE'S REALLY QUICKLY FOR US
TAYLOR ONE EXPRESSING GRATITUDE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BOUNTY
BOX PROGRAM AT THE AGRICULTURAL
INSTITUTE OF MARIN IT WAS AN
INGENIOUS WAYS FOR THAT SMALL
LOCAL FARMERS FROM ACROSS THE
BAY AREA SOUTH BAY ALL OVER-
GOT THEIR CROPS HEALTHY FOOD
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES DURING
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR MAKING THAT. POSSIBLE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF ISTER
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MY QUESTION KIDS AND FUELING
IT'S MORE FOR THE PROFESSOR IN
REGARDS TO THE MICRO CLIMATES
YOU SHOWED A LOT OF GREAT DATA
WITH THE YOUR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION BUT I KNOW WITH
OUR CLIMATE CHANGE- ISSUES THAT
WE'RE FACING UNIT I KNOW A LOT
OF TIMES IT DOESN'T GET
MENTIONED ENOUGH AND I KNOW
WE'VE- GOT ADDRESS. SLIGHTLY ON
THE LAST PANEL BY JASON BRIDGES
THE REDUCTION IN TEMPERATURES
IN YOUR GATED LANDS WHERE WE
ARE SEQUESTERING CARBON- IF THE
PROFESSOR RUN ACROSS ANY DATA
ALONG THOSE LINES I KNOW IT'S
SAID THAT IT'S ABOUT TEN TO
FIFTEEN DEGREES COOLER WITHIN
YOUR GATED LANCE VERSES IN
URBAN AREAS BUT ACTUALLY HAVING
THE DATA TO BACK IT UP IS
ALWAYS A LOT NICER. YEAH THAT'S
A BIT OF A CHALLENGING QUESTION
BECAUSE THAT A LOT OF THAT DATA
WAS DEVELOPED UNDER FLOOD
IRRIGATION TECHNIQUES. AND
THERE IS SORT OF A LOT OF APPLE
TRANSPIRATION THAT LED TO THAT
COOLING- BOTH FROM THE PLANT
AND SOIL- NOW WITH THE MICRO
IRRIGATION TECHNIQUES- WATER
USE EFFICIENCIES GIRLY HIGHER
YOU HAVE LESS SORELY REPARATION
YOU STILL HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT
OF PLANT RESPIRATION AND MAYBE
EVEN MORE BECAUSE PRODUCTIVITY
IS OFTEN INCREASED UNDER THESE
MICRO IRRIGATION SYSTEMS FOR
EXAMPLE INTIMATE DOES JUST
CONVERTING TO MY CAREER-
SUBSURFACE DRIP SYSTEMS GETS ON
AVERAGE A THIRTY PERCENT.
INCREASE SO YOU WOULD EXPECT
PERJURERS O THE SURFACE AREA
AND- ANY OPERATION FROM THAT
EXAMPLE TRACK- TRANSPIRATION
FROM THAT. AND SO. YES IT HAS
BEEN DEMONSTRATED THAT YOU'RE
GETTING ARE CAN COOL- I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE MAIN ISSUES
THOUGH IS THAT AS CLIMATE WARMS
AND- I MIGHT BE STEPPING OUT OF
BOUNDS HERE- IT'S THE NIGHTTIME
TEMPERATURES THAT REMAIN A
LITTLE HIGHER- VERSES THE
DAYTIME TEMPERATURES. WHICH ARE
A LITTLE PROBLEMATIC. BUT THAT
MAY BE OKAY BECAUSE IF THERE'S
LESS SOIL EVAPORATION AT NIGHT-
THERE'S. OR OR A BILL WELL
ANYWAY I WAS GOING TO GOING TO
SAY THAT IT YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE
CORRECT IN ASSUMING THAT THERE
IS A LITTLE BIT OF ABERRATION
BUT STILL TEMPERATURES ARE
WARMING. SO WHAT IS THE BASE
LONG BECAUSE WE SEE FOR EXAMPLE
IN TREE CROPS THERE ARE THEY
ARE BEING- AFFECTED- FURTHER
BERLE'S ATION PERIOD FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE TEMPERATURES
ARE RISING. OKAY I THINK I KNOW
IT'S SOMETHING THAT SAID THAT
THE SO I WANTED TO ASK THAT- TO
YOU SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE I
KNOW. AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
WE TALK ABOUT OTHER ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA SUCH AS HOUSING- IN
IN THE NEED TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING UNITS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT THEN WE GET INTO THINGS
LIKE URBAN SPRAWL- THERE. THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US REMEMBER-
WE DON'T NEED TO SPRAWL OUT
INTO AGRICULTURAL AREAS- IN
LOSE THESE AREAS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND THE
IMPORTANCE THAT IT IS TO KEEP
THOSE- AND KEPT THAT IN MIND
BECAUSE WE'RE- WE'RE SEEING TOO
OFTEN- AT GLANCE WILL GET SOLD
OFTEN TURN INTO HOUSING UNITS.
AND IT'S NOT ACTUALLY HELPING
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEMS THAT
WE FACE. HELPED KEEP IT. OKAY
SO I THINK WITH THAT I KNOW WE
ARE OVERTIME BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND THANK YOU FOR MAKING THE
TIME FOR A FOR HEARING- REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE INFORMATION
ALL OF OTHER MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE RECEIVED IT- AND
YOU KNOW WITH THAT LOOK FORWARD
TO A FUTURE ENGAGEMENT WITH YOU
BOTH AND- EXCITED TO WORK WITH
YOU. THIS YEAR. THANK YOU. OKAY
SO WITH THAT I JUST LEARNED OF
IT OVERSIGHT- AS IT RELATES TO
HAVING AN OPEN TELEPHONE LINE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING- AND SO
UNFORTUNATELY WE FOUND OUT OF
THIS OVERSIGHT IS TOO LATE TO
ADD A PHONE LINE AND YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY COVERT NINETEEN HAS
MADE IT VERY CHALLENGING FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO JOIN
IN PERSON HERE- CERTAINLY-
YOU'RE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ANYONE PRESENT TO OFFER
PUBLIC COMMENT- AND YOU KNOW
SOME THE WALKING ALL THE
FEEDBACK VIA EMAIL TO OUR
COMMITTEE ARE- HI COMMITTEE
EMAIL IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE- YOU CAN SEND US- SOME
CORRESPONDENCE BY A LETTER
THROUGH THE MAIL. I'D BE HAPPY
TO- THE YOU KNOW WORK WITH MY
STAFF SHOULD SOMEONE WANT TO
SCHEDULE A VIRTUAL MEETING I'D
BE HAPPY TO- SET THAT UP- TO
ENTERTAIN ANY COMMENTS- AND
OBVIOUSLY ALL THE
CORRESPONDENCE THAT WE RECEIVE
IN OUR OFFICE A DRUG COMMITTEE
WE WILL SHARE THAT WITH ALL
MEMBERS OF- OUR COMMITTEE SO
YOU KNOW WITH THAT REALLY WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE PANELISTS
WHO PARTICIPATED ARE HEARING I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS.
WHO WERE HERE AND ASK GREAT
QUESTIONS- YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
THIS IS A CRITICAL TIME FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- YOU
KNOW AS A AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO SUPPORT OUR
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY ANYWAY
THAT WE CAN UTILIZE AGRICULTURE
TO MEET CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
AND CREATE THESE PATHWAYS TO
INCENTIVIZE A LOT OF THESE
PRACTICES I THINK WHAT WE HEARD
TODAY OBVIOUSLY FINDING FINDING
FINDING. IS VERY CRITICAL-
OFFERING THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT TO- ARE-
YOU KNOW THAT THOSE THAT WORK
IN AGRICULTURE IS GONNA BE
CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS AND
VIABILITY OF IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT INDUSTRY- ONE THAT
FEEDS NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT
YOU KNOW OUR COUNTRY IN THE
WE'RE- SO BUT- WITH THAT. I
REALLY. STAFF AND- APPRECIATE
THE SERGEANTS WHO- HAVE BEEN
HERE. AND- WE STAND ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.